It's like old school,
Russian
three to do something I like about the
fact that you could smoke in here.
I liked the people can be relaxed.
I had to find a comedy club to shoot our
special word that.
Where'd you go?
Comedy cellar.
The underground.
They let you smoke.
Well,
but I left.
It was just like a rule where if you're
a performer you can get away with
because it's a part of your routine that
you get like a cabaret old still on the
books.
To don't take my word for that.
I believe I learned that from dice while
he was onstage.
Yeah,
I think you read that in the dice.
Chappelle manual.
Yeah.
Well they can get away with it,
right?
Yeah.
Dave's always smoking on stage.
No,
I don't.
I don't smoke anymore.
But I'll tell you one thing that that
year in between like,
well,
you're not allowed to smoke on stage.
That was a tough year because he used to
like smoking in the crowd smoke and you
know,
it was kind of a fun thing.
A punchline enhancer to Dave.
You do smoke on stage.
Not all the time,
like towards the end of it,
maybe not only that,
but when we were on the road and we'd do
like an hour and a half,
he'll pretend he's getting a phone call
or something.
Go smoke.
Lead me on stage by myself.
Really?
Yeah,
but it gives you a chance to like open
up a long form bit.
Now you're hearing it,
Joe.
Now you're really hearing the whole
story behind the bumping mic.
When you behind the bumping Mike,
what do you get out of here?
Smoking onstage.
It just fulfills the nicotine fix.
Or does it actually give you something?
Because they say,
I've smoked a cigarette.
I smoked one at Tony Hinchcliffe
cigarettes a couple of times before I
went onstage and you get like a pick me
up.
There's a little something.
You get an enhancement.
All right,
Jay.
I,
I'll say it right now.
It definitely is a weakness that like,
you know,
now I don't drink,
don't do anything but like coffee and
cigarettes.
It's like it's breathing for me,
but a onstage.
It does focus.
It helps focus you.
They
said it's legitimately,
they say new nicotine is actually a good
nootropic yeah.
It actually enhances cognitive function.
Like if you do a test without nicotine,
then do a test with nicotine nonusers.
Yeah,
it makes me nauseous if I accidentally
smoke a blunt and not just straight weed
or tobacco.
Like snoop handed me something the other
day and I thought it was all pop,
but there was tobacco and those things
are the shit.
There's a back and deal with it on the
paper champion.
Once you get these,
where were they at this company?
Hollywood's for.
I don't know the stores these days.
These are my favorite.
I'll check them out.
It's a Charlie Murphy got me into these
things back in the day because he would
roll them himself.
He would get those swisher sweets and he
would tear them apart and then he put
the weed inside of it and roll it out.
Oh yeah.
Old School and then a Chappelle got me
into it again because I smoked one with
him one day at the back of the comedy
store.
I was like,
damn,
this is a weird high.
What is the like you get a buzz,
it's like you're a little high,
but you're also
a little bit buzzy from love from the
tobacco.
Well,
I want to get my fan,
whatever it takes to make the jokes fly,
bro.
Whatever they were.
When they made your jacket,
they will smoke a cigarette and I'll
take like one hit of weed right before
we go on and we meet in the middle.
One hits good one hip before you've gone
too much before?
No,
no,
not in a long,
long,
long time.
You feel like I'd like one more,
but Ooh,
that's a dangerous dangerous decision.
Yeah.
You want to stay a little quick coffee
though?
I need coffee before red bull will make
me too like jumpy and nervous,
but coffee will get my brain work and
just a little bit quicker than the
audiences.
Did you guys do this one time as a goof
and then start touring with it?
Or did you just put the idea together?
Like what?
What made you decide to work together
like this?
You know,
it all started out just late night at
the comedy cellar where,
you know,
I'd be on stage and I would just see
jeff in the room and I would bring them
up and then we would just,
you know,
like throw down basically and have a
great time.
And we kept doing it and doing it and
people actually,
you know,
like they wanted to see it.
It became like this Kinda like,
are you guys going to go up together?
They would always ask us,
how are you guys going up together?
We would get the next mic go,
you know,
that kind of thing.
How it really when I was living in la or
not even when I started,
but in the last few years I'd come back
to New York.
I have an apartment in Greenwich village
near the comedy cellar and you know,
it's like cheers.
I mean with knows your name,
you,
you land,
you go sort of go into my empty
apartment.
I'll go,
let's see who's at the seller and get
something to eat.
And I started booking my flights where I
land around midnight day.
When would inevitably have the 1:00
AM spot and I would,
I just wanted to get my yas out and he
would just bring me up and he'd sit by
the piano and I would goof off or I'd
sit by the piano and he would tell jokes
when we started setting each other up
and it organically,
our friends started popping up with us
or people from the audience or whatever,
Bachelorette party and we just started
making an act out of it without even
realizing it.
Yeah.
Wow.
It was like a,
it was a lot of fun like in the
beginning especially because it was
like,
you know,
he really kept me on my toes.
Like listening is like the hardest thing
listening on stage,
you know,
because once you're up there alone,
locked in,
you know,
like you control all,
like facets of,
of the performance.
But when there's another president up
there,
especially jeff and I,
we have so many different skill sets.
So like it was really cool to work off
of him.
A brought up my game a bit.
It definitely made me quicker and faster
and funnier to have to like,
you know,
really pretty much roll with it,
and I,
I think that the crowd dug that too.
It was like a different energy than just
straight up like a showcase,
you know,
the one thing that you would do on a
podcast so you wouldn't normally do on
stage which is look at someone else and
it took me a long time and I think I
could
a million arguments on looking at each
other like sports.
If you look at you're
never going to not catch that ball,
but when you're wondering what the other
guy's doing and you're kind of going
like this,
but when I,
it's like w we connect now and instead
of doing like in tandem one at a time
jokes,
we do jokes together.
That's how like that's a weird thing.
We're twins,
we're twins will do an act and one guy
will do the setup and the other guys and
then they do a double punch line to
gather.
We're hoping for that one day to
coordinated.
I feel like it's one plus one equals
three.
You know,
two headliners get together by choice,
not by necessity,
but then,
and then Dave,
you know,
I,
it took a lot.
Dave did not want to go to Montreal.
We went up to the comedy festival and I
basically begged him.
Yeah,
do it together.
Yeah.
I just,
I saw it mostly it's just like a fun
thing to do.
Seller.
Yeah.
Like it was just like a cool,
like,
you know,
basically like just let it all hang out.
But Jeff saw like I guess the next step
to it.
So
I always just thought it was something
that if the comics wanted to see it that
bad and then more and more comics corner
to come on stage with us and then more
and more like Jim Carrey came to one of
our big shows in Montreal and,
and,
and all the headlines are sort of
popping up with us and I thought Oh,
this is more than just us as a hobby.
Like this is something that no one else
is really doing.
Yeah.
I got really into it really quick and I
tried to call it clumping mix and Dave
was like,
no,
it's like it's too on the nose.
That's good for a title.
We don't have any other structure to our
show.
By the way.
We don't rehearse.
He has a flip phone.
I can't even talk to him before the
show.
We don't have any plan.
What's stressful job?
Why do you have a flip phone?
Why?
I'm trying to stay off the grid.
Dude,
you saw me with a sword in front of the
flag.
I'm ready to go.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to be activated.
No,
I'll tell you.
This is the best
title for it.
Jeff is really a good producer and all
those different things.
All the same skillsets.
I don't have like he's produced
producer.
He know show busy,
all those different things.
But like I was like we should have like
really like workshops.
Some other names like,
like to Castello's looking for an Abbott
Nichols
and May I
teams out there.
I'm not going to say there aren't,
but the thing is that like we're not
really a team,
like we both have our separate stuff,
but when we get together it's like this
kind of like almost like,
um,
you know,
like within 48 hours we're a team again,
it's only really difficult,
but I think we rock out in certain
situations.
Like I want to go through it with you
because you've done every venue now
you've an outdoor,
you've done theater,
you've done casino.
I think we are one of the best casino
acts I'll say.
Right.
I think we really are.
I think at a casino we take it to the
level that needs to be.
Especially in a d level casino.
I'm talking like,
like you're like hoping.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
They're hoping for like a,
you know,
like one of those electric poker thing
like
that kind of the woods yet.
Well Fox would we do rock the casinos
because I guess they let them smoke my
people.
That's true about casinos,
but it's also a very body audience and
you can say anything.
You don't have to hold back at all and
you know,
we just fearless.
Um,
I have a filter up,
but he is fearless.
He really has actually been changed.
Is that place in Temecula,
right?
That place is actually nice.
What am I thinking of?
I'm thinking of what's the plan?
What's the fucking place on the five
playboy one marina.
You sell the hustler because that would
be great if we just do one like that.
Planned Pa.
That's our best one too.
I love that one.
The other one,
it's an old steel mill,
but now it's a casino in deadline.
The,
I think it is Bethlehem.
We always have our best shows.
They're so excited.
Man.
First roadshow.
Very.
Yeah.
Those weird road gigs and the one we
were going to cancel it,
but we never canceled and like Utah or
something.
Uh,
we did the Oklahoma,
right?
One.
Oklahoma.
Yeah.
You guys did in Oklahoma run.
Well he did.
I did a one casino that I drove through
like this crazy storms in the next one.
Oklahoma.
Man,
you can drive as fast as you want.
Fuck.
They don't care.
Montana hidden even have dry.
They didn't have no speed limits.
Isn't that cool?
They just had to impose speed limits
within the last decade or two because of
the federal government.
They said,
look,
we're not going to fix your fucking
Rhodes to tell people that can't go 150
miles an hour.
I love it.
That's a Montana though,
you know,
burst says that Oklahoma's fucking
amazing.
It was fantastic.
Yeah.
I want to play there for sure.
But I was playing the casinos and then I
met Jeff at this one.
That's like right on the border of Texas
and uh,
you know,
Seinfeld plays there fact Kerrville.
Yeah.
Seinfeld plays there.
Kerrville.
Townson.
Yeah.
And it was like a rough roughly
Toquerville yeah.
But he's got it down to a science man,
you know,
fly in,
fly out,
that kind of thing.
You know,
we're in bed,
we're in bed at night,
I guess if you have a nice life in a
nice house.
But I like going and looking around the
local places and eating the local fair.
I still kind of love that.
Well,
he's in that weird place to where I
don't think he can go places.
Yeah,
that's true.
We can't rely on the street.
You're like,
Holy Shit.
It's held.
It's gotta be weird,
Joe.
That's what we do at this show because
we're both a little older now.
We,
we really eat.
That's what we do.
We really enjoy it.
What's your like?
Do you like steaks and stuff?
Oh Dude,
you should hang with us because we eat
cow steaks.
He likes to eat like steak and shit.
Like game of thrones giving kids their
breakfast.
Kids eat elk.
They really do well.
Well it's delicious.
I wish I,
I need to set up a kitchen here and cook
for you guys.
Oh,
that will be great.
Fucking fantastic.
Kids eat for breakfast.
If you ate it,
you'd want to get it more.
Really.
What does it taste like?
Meat scale.
Like a bison like him a little bit
more.
Uh,
unusual.
Better than venison.
Deer.
Venison slowly on a pellet grill.
And then I sear it on the outside of the
end.
Oh yeah.
So your thanksgiving Mr.
out of control.
Well,
this year.
No,
I'm just here.
We just did the normal Turkey thing,
Turkey in a deep.
Uh,
but he caught it with his own hands.
That's true.
Roof of the studio.
We did the peanut oil thing.
We deep fried peanut law makes it
better.
Yeah.
But it's like it's a scam.
How do all this stuff?
He's like,
every time I meet you have like two
other skills,
like how do you do this stuff?
You're pretty busy.
I need things to occupy my brain.
I just have one of those brains.
The only way I'm at peace as if I have a
bunch of difficult shit that I do all
the time and constantly challenging
themselves.
I have to.
That's how my brain works.
You know,
everybody has their own weird kink.
Kink is I need to be exhausted just for
your brain itself.
It needs to be fed.
My brain's needs.
Shit.
Do it needs things to concentrate on.
If I,
if I don't have things to concentrate
on,
the things that are really difficult.
I uh,
I started playing tricks on myself.
I mean,
mental or physical?
Both.
Mental and physical.
Yeah.
I'd have to have both.
How do you handle the time management
with family and career and get up early.
Get up early this morning I was up at
6:30
kids.
Go to school there.
They're leaving the house by seven.
Take the dog running.
I'm gone for two hours.
Then I come back,
get a bunch of shit done at the house
then come over here.
Then you know,
hang out with you guys for a few hours.
Then I'm going to lift and then I'm
going to go to the store and uh,
do couple sets.
I have a good time doing like a 16 hour
day there.
Right?
Well yeah,
but the thing is like the way it works
really good with me with families that
most of the stuff I'm doing either while
my kids are at school or while my kids
were asleep.
So by the time I leave I have a 10:00
spot at the store.
Dirty asleep.
They'd go to bed at like 8:30.
How old are they now?
The youngest ones are eight and 10.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's a,
they'd go to bed,
get up at like 6:30,
they go to bed at like 8:30.
So that's perfect time for me.
Then you got your own.
When's the last time you just quit?
Something in the middle was like fuck
it,
I can't figure this out.
Like what?
A bit of a team.
Sometimes bits.
You just got abandoned them and come
back to them and a couple of weeks or a
couple months or a couple of years
sometimes.
Yeah.
Everybody has that one like great
beginning of a bit.
And they're like,
where does this go?
And then you just keep throwing it out,
thrown it out,
thrown it out.
That's the cool thing with jeff is that
like,
um,
you know,
we both bring material up on stage,
but at the end of the day it's the stuff
that just comes to us like that,
you know,
in the moment stuff,
especially with the audience.
That's the stuff that I really think,
uh,
you know,
we should give a shout out to Andrew,
the director of core capturing all that
Jeff's friend who is now a one of the
best directors out there.
Man,
he really,
uh,
you know,
once again it was jeff's choice and he
did the job and then some.
I mean,
it's so good the
way he put it all together,
you know,
when you guys have,
it's more than just you guys going
onstage.
There's a bunch of other stuff
happening.
There's a bunch of people are dropped by
three,
three episode series.
Oh,
really?
Docu series.
So I don't know if you saw the jinx on
Hbo about Robert Durst electrode wires,
that phenomenal documentary.
I heard my buddy Andrew directly
directed that he also directed capturing
the Freeman's years ago was an Oscar
nominated documentary.
What was that about?
That was about a family of convicted,
actually child molester math science
teachers in Long Island.
Oh,
father son member.
The based on a short that he did about a
party clown who's family wound up being
implicated in this crazy controversy.
Oh,
that's right,
that's right.
Oh,
that was him,
Huh?
Yeah.
Wow.
Andrew and I are tight and Dave and I
were sort of going back and forth on who
could sort of direct us who had no our
moves but yet had the experience and
doesn't like anybody that's too hip.
I just want,
I want,
I like it straight ahead of Andrew.
I liked it straight ahead and I,
and I also think some of these comedy
specials or over directed,
so I didn't want to fall into this whole
like,
you know,
instead of like lighting the stage,
you guys hold lanterns,
that kind of thing.
Know bumped lanterns and then we'll
have,
you know,
like that kind of thing.
Like,
you know,
that'll be the essence of the humor that
could happen to.
Exactly.
So.
But he really,
he really was cool and he really was
patient and he really brought a lot of
things outside of my wheelhouse.
You know,
it's a collaboration,
which is another thing you're not used
to doing when you do your own special,
like,
you know,
you're like,
Hey,
I want to do it this way.
I've been doing it this way and I want
it that way,
but we have other voices in the room and
uh,
you know,
other ideas.
Then,
you know,
you've got to like pretty much mesh
together into something that,
you know,
pretty much I guess captured the spirit
of it and also like hopefully the
funding of it,
you know,
well,
if you've got that guy as your director
mean,
that's fucking incredible.
It looks cool.
And he also understood our personalities
and our friendship.
You know,
I've been chasing Dave my whole career.
I always just an open mic or I would go
watch dave or,
you know,
I always thought like,
if no one's gonna make it in our crew
until Dave makes it.
Dave was always the one that everybody,
even when Ray Romano was popping on TV,
he would call it down to watch Dave
attell,
you know,
riff and you know,
my first tv spot was a seven hour train
ride with Dave to Canada.
You know,
when we were really young and I've heard
three versions of the story.
Joe,
what's the first version?
No,
it's like,
it's like Canada or Syracuse.
No,
it was candidate,
it was,
it was a Hamilton,
Canada,
whatever.
We took a train from the.
Anyway,
I'm just saying Hamilton.
It's called.
Isn't that an Ontario?
I guess so,
but uh,
I'm just saying I've been.
Dave.
Dave is my favorite comic.
I didn't know that until we really
started working together.
I consider it consider contemporary
weird you out and he's like,
you're his favorite comic.
I'm a little bit and know,
be honest.
Yeah.
But no,
I,
I see,
I see jeff is like beyond unique,
like there's nobody like him and what he
does and what he is able to do is
really,
it's really,
it's not only fun to watch but it's
really like,
you know,
you're a self starter.
He's a self starter.
Like it's great to see self starters who
find success because it really is
difficult to like take something and
like make it not only financially
successful but also like something that,
that we all respect and love,
you know.
And that's,
you know,
I'd say the roasting thing that Jeff
really pretty much has rebranded into,
like,
you know,
every,
every possible way you can do it is
always good because he's behind it,
you know,
when it's not,
when it's not really with him,
then you're like,
I'm not so sure.
There's other people who are really good
at it too.
But I'm just saying that like,
you know,
that is when we're on the road and
people will scream out the car door.
It's the roast master.
I mean like,
you know,
I had my insomniac time,
but he like 20,
30 times that in terms of like,
recognition.
I mean it's just amazing.
It is.
We're the year.
You're synonymous with roasts.
Yeah.
You know,
people say roast,
they think Jeff Ross,
I earned it because when people laughed
at me and thought,
oh,
that's a dead art.
It's a lost art.
It's antiquated.
It's Corny.
It's old guys.
I stuck by it and said,
no,
it's alternative comedy.
No one's doing it.
I get to,
I get to hang with legends like Buddy
Hackett and Milton Berle,
you know,
and I stuck to it because it was a lot.
There was a,
there was a time where I was like
embarrassed,
like,
oh,
I'm going to be pigeonholed as the roast
guy.
Were you embarrassed?
Not In my,
I don't know if embarrassed is the right
word,
but uncomfortable.
Yeah,
because you're like,
well,
I want to be more than that.
When was this around?
This was probably 10 years ago,
and I was in Vegas,
Chappelle,
again,
words of wisdom.
He's like,
dude,
that's your lane.
Make that a five lane highway and ride
it.
And that's kind of what we started when
I started doing sort of really owning it
and loving it and to the credit of the
world as we became more pussies in the
world.
Like roasting became more and more
potent and important.
Yeah.
And the world needs to develop thick
skin and I think roasting honors people
and it's done with love,
but it also kind of toughens us up a
little bit.
Well,
I think it's of the time when I came
back to the comedy store,
first thing I came back to watch was
roast battle.
Yeah.
And uh,
I hadn't really known I'd heard,
but I didn't really know where it was.
And I remember that night.
I remember that night really well
because I remember thinking,
Holy Shit,
this is so mean.
It is.
Sometimes I'll be like woke,
you guys go deep,
but really good.
We were at the other club,
the Improv.
Sure.
Thanks.
That's a great tobacco though.
I'll take a,
I'll take a real leaf.
The leaf,
I can deal with it,
deal with it.
Doesn't have any inside.
Is My company going crumble because of
this.
I'm not going to get audited by NASA.
Pumped him up.
He went down with,
he went back up,
Tesla went down and then it went out.
Really went down six percent.
Then it went up.
Nine studios still smells a little
Muskie,
but that night when I walked in there,
I remember thinking,
this is a joke writing thing.
This isn't just a simple as um,
the art of the insult.
Yeah,
it's,
but it's,
it's a joke writing and one of the
things I love about roast battle is how
Moses makes everybody hug at the end of
it.
It's very cool sort of judging it and
people were pushing each other and
screaming at each other.
And I wrote the rules of roast battle,
original material only.
Um,
no physical contact.
Yeah,
that's scary.
And every battle went to the hug.
I've seen that with them.
Rap battles guys punch each other in the
face.
Rap battles also like the way more mean
version of roast battle.
Those fucking guys I've seen some just
horrible,
horrible shit.
People say to each other and Moses like
he owns that,
that,
that circus.
You've got to admire the fact that he
can week after week make that work.
One of the reasons why it works,
he's so likable.
Like Brian is such a nice guy.
He's such a,
he's such a good,
good hearted,
sweet person.
We were at the Improv that night.
You hadn't been at the comedy store and
years and years and years and years and
I don't know all the details and it
never really was part of part of my and
you were asking me about Roche Pat or
somebody started asking me about it in
front of you and I saw you getting
curious and you get more curious and you
were maybe a little homesick for the
comedy store.
Who knows?
And I said,
come on,
let's go jump in my car and you're like,
I'll meet you there.
And you sat up on the balcony where the
judges sit and you hadn't been in the
belly room in five years maybe.
Who knows?
Seven,
seven years and you're sitting there and
Moses does a double take and he's too
afraid.
He doesn't know what to do.
He doesn't really know you.
You haven't been back there,
you haven't been in the store.
And finally I say comedy store legend
back after a long time,
say hi to Joe wrote real low key intro
and I've been in that room a lot for
roast battle.
I'd never heard anything like place
reverberated like I thought we were
going to fall into the main room and it
was it.
That was it you even back everyday since
I had to go back to.
Because Ari was filming his comedy
central specials tonight.
It's one of the reasons why I had to go
to Rosebud and I loved him.
I really love them.
There's no way I was going to miss a
special.
I was like a half to go there.
I don't want to go there the night of
his special.
Let me just go there a day early.
So I went there a day early and you,
uh,
you end up judging roast battle on
comedy central and Dylan.
Oh,
you're part of our,
your,
your royalty over there.
Earl Skakel came out shirtless with a
gold chain with a code on this day.
That was one of the greatest entrances
I've ever anybody take
onstage and he fucking murdered.
He was on fire on fire.
It's like the art of the insult.
You might not be the strongest
headlining act,
but if you can put five jokes together,
you can take somebody down.
But here's the question,
why is it that so many people excel at
that,
like,
especially young comics,
but they can't seem to figure out a way
to generate that kind of energy during a
regular set
different?
I think they don't get stage time.
I think that's really what it is.
There's a lot of that for sure that this
is their moment.
So they throw all in.
But can I say as an outsider since I
never was really a west coast,
you know,
comic like you guys,
uh,
is that the comedy store from back in
the day to before the roast battling to,
to the roast Batak like an amazing
difference.
I remember walking in there and it was
like,
it was like a haunted house,
you know,
you're like,
where is everybody?
What's going on?
Sam Kennison played here,
you know,
and then like,
you go onstage and it was like,
you know,
12 tourists in the room and then a bunch
of comics in the back.
And then after the rose petal,
I like the energy.
You could just see it just went out like
through the roof of just like it was the
place to hang and like it became like
when you're in town you want to go by
the store and just check it out and like
go on stage and you know,
the crowds there became way better and I
think that you were part of that have
really helped reenergizing that club
hundred percent.
That's what I felt when I went back,
I was like,
this is a different place.
Even Lil rel howery said there's no
other comedy competition where other
comics come to watch true 100 percent
cheer on their friends or kind of roll
their eyes at the ones that they don't
want to win and there's a fraternity
there.
I feel like comedians and I feel like
we're a cult in a weird way sometimes I
feel like I'm a comedian before I'm even
an American,
like comedians from all over the world
and I feel like I know them my whole
life and roast battle is now
international.
Yeah,
so that's a great story.
It really is a movement like that where
it was sort of a corny thing that nobody
really understood the roasting.
I couldn't even try out roast jokes when
I first started.
It was like so mean.
If I would stand there with a piece of
paper and read 10 William Shatner jokes
people.
You were doing that one night at the
Improv.
I'm trying to remember who you were
practicing for.
People have the same people that would
be at the roast.
It'd be dying.
It's hard to put yourself in that roast
mindset.
Like when you go to see the gross
mindset,
it's like going to see a fight.
Say if you went to see a fight and you
knew you're going to go see a fight,
you can handle the fact that the fight
was going on,
but if you just show up at the movies to
people,
start head start.
We can agree to to horrific shit.
If we just know it's going to take place
in advance
as part of that and it,
and it is a sport.
Roasting has 100 percent of a sport.
It's definitely a game because there's
strategy.
It's not just
jokes,
it's like you're trying to disarm
someone's material towards you.
Maybe like sometimes guys will go at
themselves first and then go out the
their opponent like in the same joke,
but they go,
they're already sort of there.
It's very smart.
People are being clever with because
they've been doing it for a few years
now,
so they've seen people bomb,
they've seen people murder
other strategies like any other sports
and you punch back and you have your,
you have your a retort ready and you
know there's all kinds of other little
things like,
you know,
maybe don't mention the obvious thing
till the end and then you're going to.
Sure,
yeah,
yeah.
I don't want to give too many secrets
away,
but better roast battle battlers.
We'll study the game tape if you will,
and figure all this stuff out.
And you know,
five jokes.
I mean it's not easy.
No,
it's not easy.
If you trip or stumble,
can you recover?
Tony Hinchcliffe that goddamn assassin.
If that shit,
that motherfucker.
He's an assassin at roasts.
He's got an evil little black spot in
his heart and he likes to open up
whenever those roasts come at.
Those jokes are vicious and clean,
tight.
But I,
I've generationally,
it doesn't,
it's not unfortunately do off the top of
our head.
I mean if you can do that also,
but tony takes it seriously and it's
like,
like I say,
the,
it's an art.
Yes.
That's also the skill of joke writing,
which is like in today's world of more
storytelling and all that kind of stuff
that it's,
it's,
it's few and far between where you
actually see like someone who can put
together a couple of jokes in a row and
you're like,
wow,
that was a great run.
You know,
like everybody has one good joke and
then like,
you know,
maybe a couple of tags but like to
actually have a great run.
You know,
that's the thing that always excites me
about comedy and when he'll tell you
like when work together,
he'll go what new stuff they have and
like we'll just throw it up there and
like I'll try and um,
you know,
basically work it out on stage because I
know it's not like one of my own bits,
like a form bit yet.
It's like something that I can work with
him and that's fun too.
That also like opened your mind to a
whole other world of like joke writing
and I'm sure especially you're doing it
right next to another comic.
Yeah,
we started,
we wrote it is difficult.
We always start by talking about each
other.
They looked like an umpire during a rain
delay.
I'm actually wearing the same stuff
right now,
especially jeff mixes it up a bit.
It's easier for me.
Makes a statement.
Let is a very clear David tail outfit.
This is,
it makes a statement.
Flip phone.
What?
What's,
what is it?
I know how to delete a hard drive.
I do.
Creep it up.
Why do you still didn't answer about the
flip phone?
Why do you have a flip phone?
Well,
I like the flip phoney like you don't
get distracted with the web because it
takes forever to get the web on there.
But uh,
it's just,
I don't know.
I don't really like technology.
I don't like the web.
I feel like,
um,
you know,
there's something about the virtual
experience and the live experience that
like we're,
we're really in that world now of like
coming to see someone live is getting
harder and harder,
but like they'll know all your clips on
Youtube,
you know?
So I don't know.
I think more people are going to CB
beloved than ever before.
Well Joe,
not me.
If there's any reason for that at all,
it's definitely not your,
your act because he's got to be content.
It's your lack of connection with the
Internet.
If you are connected more with the
Internet,
more people would be going to see you.
I'm not a good promoter.
I know that I ever sent,
believed that 100 percent believe that
because you're,
you're,
it's hard to talk complimentary about
someone there.
Right in front of you.
You're,
you're brilliant.
As a joke,
right?
Are you one of the most prolific?
I know one of the most clever that I
know,
but you're also the.
You have less ego than anyone I've ever
met in my life.
You're like some weird fucking Tibetan
monk dude that's been sitting up in some
cave somewhere mean you one of the best
comics ever in my opinion.
You're so.
You're so low key.
It freaks people out sometimes.
I,
I'm all about the.
I really love the hang.
Like he was saying like the cult of the
comics,
like us hanging in,
like coming from you dude.
That's like extra special.
So thank you.
To get recognized.
I don't like any of that stuff,
but why I think I've,
I think there's a correlation.
You're my own self hate more bandwidth
for what you're doing.
Your stand up,
don't.
You're looking at.
It's a good mixture because you've
obviously you've obviously been really
successful with like staying in this
group particularly after you stopped
drinking and everything.
You're,
you're in this tight group present.
That's what I can say.
But you're sat at the Improv that I saw
was about like six months.
We were at the Improv together,
something like that.
Six months.
God Damn.
That was funny shit.
But all the fun.
You know,
it's funny like when you talk about like
I love,
there's no harder fan now than your
fans.
I mean like they know comedy,
they know a lot of things and they
totally respect the art form and like
the craft of it and that's thanks to you
and you're out there doing it.
It's not like,
you know,
it's like back in the day I was a comic.
You're out there every night to when you
go on the road.
So it's like you're talking from now,
now from the past and you get it.
How like,
um,
I,
I feel like the web,
the web stuff helps and hurts comedy to
some degree,
but it probably helps more than I'm
giving it credit because it really did
connect to people.
It really did connect with more people.
You know?
I
think it helps or hurts.
I think there's always been shit comedy
and there's always people that are doing
really well,
but there's always been inspiring people
and there's always been thieves.
There's always been all the bad things
that exist now and now it is.
It's like way more people can find you
and those people.
It does translate into clubs and seats
it they do want to come out and the
thing about the show,
the reason why this works is because we
can all talk about it in a way that a
person doesn't do it,
can still understand it and then go,
oh,
there's these guys like this is what
you could be into.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Rebuilding muscle cars,
playing chess,
whatever the fuck it is that you're
into.
When people get really into something is
a very similar thing that happens.
Will you get together with other people
that are also really into it and really
good at it and he'd go,
well,
how are you?
I'm always asking like,
do you write it out?
Like what do you do?
Do you just work it out on stage d?
How much time do you spend alone with
the bit and how much time do you spend?
How much do you love?
Just because a lot of guys don't like to
do anything outside of,
right little tiny bullet points and then
let it all express itself naturally on
stage.
Some of the best guys ever.
Right.
So it's hard to say what's right or
what's wrong because
there's a lot of work to comedy that
people don't get which is the writing,
but it's also the listening to yourself
like a taping and listening.
That's the thing I have been doing.
I have not been doing lately.
We worked on this thing.
I'm working on other stuff and it's like
data is the thing where when I go back
and go like,
you know,
when I was really hardcore into the,
into like,
you know,
material turning an hour,
that was the thing where it's like you
almost have to like,
like you telling me you have that tank,
that's where like go in there with your
act like especially like a hard show on
a Friday,
late,
late show and like listen to it.
That to me is like a form of torture to
like all the bits that don't work late
on Friday.
Right.
I disagree.
I believe he's very optimistic.
I'm very pessimistic.
Optimistic.
We'll.
He really like.
He really is like super optimistic.
Friday,
late shows.
He loves everybody.
I like the active audience.
It fuels me.
I feel like a lion tamer up there and
when Davis beside me,
I'm indestructable what's probably a
really good man.
So for people that don't want to be
quiet to don't want to yell out.
Yeah,
get rowdy and drag people onstage.
We go into the crowd.
We do all those different things that
like,
you know,
I'll say it,
I'll say it.
There's a lot of things that we do are
like old school comedy in terms of like
old school hockey,
like it's just no longer done.
It's like you could say it's,
it might be a little cheesy,
a little this,
a little of that,
but at the end of the day it's just
inappropriate,
fun,
silly.
Like move to the next bit.
Like remember,
we were looking into the edit and I go,
hey,
I got to tell you there's like a hundred
punchlines in this thing.
So even if like,
you know,
the law of averages like turtle swimming
into the ocean,
if only like seven or great,
that's still a lot for an upper netflix
special.
I mean,
honestly I'm not,
I'm not patting ourselves on the back,
but that's pretty good.
Our show is the episodes or three
episodes of Friday.
Well the first one's called Friday or
Saturday and Sunday there three nights.
Oh Wow.
And I love that Friday crowd.
And we had like Nikki Glaser,
Amy Schumer,
Rachel Feinstein,
Michelle Wolf.
You're talking about all the people that
showed because we really like jeff
called in these amazing people.
Shut up.
Gilbert was hilarious.
Gilbert was,
he completed us.
You know what I'm talking about?
Like he was the third piece of this,
like ancient,
like scroll.
Once we found out,
I was like,
where's he been?
Gilbert is the thing.
Because you can give us like,
yeah,
that is the best one to savage.
Yeah.
I mean he's.
What do you think of Gilbert?
Like if okay,
like your kids or whatever.
Now I'm trying to think of like if you
were like 16 years old,
what would you think of guilt?
Like he's so out of there,
like,
like wheelhouse in terms of like,
what is that?
I mean I think he's classic.
I think he's like nobody else.
Tim,
I think I probably thought he was really
funny when I was 16,
when I was 16.
I was really getting into standup.
Oh No.
My parents took me to see live in the
sunset strip when I was 14.
I guess it was a movie theater.
When I first discovered Gilbert,
he was like on the MTV awards imitating
dice.
So to me he was like not hero comic.
He was the guy that made fun of the
hero.
Right.
He had the,
you know,
he was,
he was always like,
people would talk about him in
interview.
So it was always revered by other
comedians.
You know,
he's a guy that's always been like,
he's a wild man,
like a legit wild man.
He murdered in our show,
like standing.
Oh,
we got a standing o w lately have like
friends from our life in the audience,
my aunt and his family and like Bruce
Willis is there and he does a bit with
this,
but I had my friend Craig Moss from high
schools in the audience with his wife
and kids and Dave starts walking around
the village underground looking for my
guest list.
Craig Moss,
where's Craig Moss?
So finally,
like they started goofing on,
this guy was just in the audience.
So that was a long jump in and go and I
jump in and go,
Oh,
you know,
Craig,
when my parents died,
craig was my best friend in a new town.
He was,
you know,
so I'm explaining to the audience and
Dave who this guy is and how much he did
for me as a young man.
And uh,
and then Gilbert jumps up out of the
audience and just screams,
doesn't even need a microphone.
He was like,
when my parents were alive,
Greg came over and
killed them and says,
perfect timing.
He never,
he does.
He's just his delivery.
He's an animal.
No filter with him.
And that's the beauty of him,
like,
you know,
I'm always like,
ah,
I don't know what,
how they're going to take.
He's like,
boom,
that's it.
I think I'm going to say three times.
You know,
the kids who love comedy would love him,
but I was 16.
I mean,
I,
I would listen to everything.
I always like a mix of different types
of comics.
Like that episode,
Bob Saget and Hassan Minhaj or the other
guests at one point were all up there
together and you,
these are guys who might not even know
each other in real life,
but the comedy kind of brings it
together.
That's awesome.
It's like a party mixed with a roast
mixed with A.
I don't even know Dave.
No,
it's really cool because Jeff's family,
like wherever we would go on the road,
just family,
you know,
it'd be like,
can I get your comps?
Because I,
you know,
I've got like three third cousins.
I didn't know there were Jews in
Oklahoma,
but evidently there were five distinct
23 and me people out there for me.
And I was like,
it was funny to see because I'm really a
lone wolf,
like I'm on the road alone,
you know,
I go out there,
I do my thing and jeff really does like,
he's very with his family,
so I give him a lot of credit for that.
Like,
you know,
they're all invited to come hang out in
the green room and all that kind of
stuff.
So that's cool.
And he brought that on stage with your
aunt.
I thought that was like one of the best
moments of the whole show.
You know,
we bring up my aunt is the first episode
is,
is my aunt Bruce Willis,
Michelle Wolf.
Amy Schumer,
Nikki Glaser,
Rachel.
So it's like a weird mix of.
But you know what for,
for just to say one more thing about
Dave and the flip phone and like how the
process works.
Dave is also the most,
like you say,
president,
but also informed like he knows all the
references,
he knows what's going on in the world.
So he's not like he's living in a cave
man under the,
under the eye.
I keep my eye out there.
So what do you do?
Do you read newspapers?
I have a raven sent me,
sent me the most important news from
Westeros isn't,
uh,
by uh,
he's in the back reading and like really
like getting in touch with the world and
the audience and he's the first one to
say,
Oh,
we're in Vegas.
Let's talk about this.
That's going on in Vegas.
Let's talk about that in Vegas.
You know,
it.
He'll say an unstaged to me.
Like he'll bring up all this relevant
stuff where like,
I'm the son of a caterer.
I'm more about this live experience.
Who's in the audience?
Who is here
keeping it to like,
that's that show.
And I think you agree with it.
It's like,
Yo agree with it too is like each show
is its own thing,
right?
So it's like,
you know,
the fact that it's always like some guy
taping in the back,
you're like,
dude,
why are you doing that?
Because this is your experience right
now.
And you know,
you know,
like Stan Hope,
who is my favorite comic,
Doug Stan hope is like,
he was the first guy that like we both
talked about like this whole thing of
like why do people think that like,
you know,
capturing this show is like important.
And like,
you know,
they're also disposable.
It's like beautiful,
like fireworks,
you know,
it's like,
it's never gonna.
It's never gonna happen again.
Like that,
you know,
so you might as well just soak it all in
instead of trying to capture it.
And I think when,
when we talk about like topical stuff,
I do that for like as a joke raggedy
thing,
but also as a,
keeping the act alive because I feel
like my job in this team is to push it
forward.
Like,
you know,
it's like,
Okay Jeff,
what else is happening?
Like to keep moving it.
Otherwise we can't.
We can always get into a loop of like,
you know,
just putting each other down or like
working the crowd.
So I like to move it forward.
And I think that the,
uh,
the cool thing about that is that like
it does,
it does move forward to an end,
you know,
people are making those videos,
they're not making those videos to look
back on them to making those videos so
that other people could see it.
Right.
But the difference between today and the
past,
are you for that or you are against it?
I'm not,
I'm neither.
I think your,
your personal experience is going to be
better if you just watch it,
but I'm not,
you.
Maybe you,
maybe you just get more of a jolly off
of filming a clip and putting that clip
on facebook and they're getting a
million downloads.
Yeah,
I just know that like when I go to a
place and I'm working on new material,
I want it to be figured out and then
then put it on the way I want it.
But I totally understand what you're
saying,
which is like,
you know,
the uh,
like it's,
it's a,
it's an open,
it's an open
world now and it's just like the idea of
controlling is like an antiquated idea.
But I think that for me,
at least as the joke writer,
it's like I just want it to where it's
where it's going to be and then get it
out.
You understand?
They're not going to completely agree.
I think we,
if we established an etiquette,
you know,
and most comedy clubs say you can't
film.
There's a reason.
Yeah.
I don't know what,
like I have a bit right now that I'm
working on and I've only done it twice
and it's all over the fucking place in
the.
If I somehow or another released it,
like if I had to do a Netflix special
tomorrow and it had to do that bit,
I'd be fucked.
I'd be like,
what is this?
This malformed gelatinous preposterous.
Yeah.
You're working on if a joke yet,
but sick.
I know for a fact that six months from
now there's fruit in this.
I know the subject is,
there's something to it to figure out
what that something is and it's gonna
take a while and it's going to be a lot
of missteps.
Yeah.
There's just no way around it.
And the only way for us to do this,
it's like if you are a musician,
I'm sure it feels awesome to practice in
front of a crowd,
but you can practice at home.
Like you can actually get the band
together and play the whole song.
Right?
We can't do that.
I'm glad you brought that up because
people always bring music as like,
you know,
it's kind of like music.
I'm like,
it's Kinda not like music,
the audience.
It's not like music at all.
If anything I really,
you know,
talk about like self hate for a long
time.
I'm like,
how come like,
my bits don't rock like within six
months.
And I'm like,
you know,
then I started like,
like directors and writers and when I,
everybody has first drafts,
everybody has it and like the best
people have multiple drafts and it's the
same thing with a joke where it's like
it'll work and then it won't work.
And then you'll change a line and then
it'll work better and they won't.
And you're feeling it out.
You're feeling out that you and your
head are filling in the holes that you
only can see because it's,
you're the creator and I love that
process,
but it also is terrifying.
You know,
it really is like where is it going to
go?
But basically saying,
okay,
that's finished now because it got like
a little laugh.
You're like,
I'm not satisfied.
There's something.
Yeah.
But you have a,
you have a real issue with this because
they will get a joke,
you know,
I'm sure he's the creator and he knows
where the destroyer are.
Go ahead.
But no one is more connected to him.
Then me watching the process,
right.
He's on tour and doing like,
you know,
a week of shows.
I know,
we know each other's moves and we see
how it develops.
He'll finally get a joke,
not where it's killing,
where it's like a showstopper,
like killing,
like what do we do now where I run
around a circle,
like the jokes hitting so hard that we
have to do something while there are
laughing,
you know,
take a sip or some will just roll around
on the floor and I'll destroy it.
And then the next night I'll go,
Dave,
what's your workout routine like?
I'll give him a softball layup to go
like this joke.
And he'll look at me like I'm speaking
another language because I'm already
just be like in his eyes.
Fuck you joe.
I'm not repeating
myself night today.
And he'll deconstruct and completely
rearrange the same joke.
I will.
I will turn that funny until like a
boring couch.
Ikea that joke into a snooze fest.
Isn't that so the mindset that keeps you
present while bit and keeps him present?
It keeps me like I really am letting
down the team.
They're like,
feed me,
feed me.
And I'm like,
no.
But,
uh,
I think that's the full of it.
I also like have a problem with it.
If a joke works continuously somewhere,
I'm like,
there's something wrong with that.
Attacks goes wrong.
Netflix special.
And you're not using your aim material.
No,
dude,
I,
I had,
uh,
you know,
I think of the jokes is children.
I gave up a lot of my,
uh,
you know,
my first born there or the ugly ones,
my pharmacist joke,
my homeless joke.
It's because it's so important to have
that mindset to be a great club comic.
Right?
Because the show has to be its own
thing,
you know,
that's,
that keeps you like,
restart
for every show.
There's nothing worse.
There's nothing worse than seeing
somebody go over and over and over
there.
Same thing every year.
You see them.
It's terrible.
That's sad.
Well,
because it could be so much better.
That's what you like as a person who's a
comic.
You understand what they're doing.
They just don't want to take any
chances.
But as a person who's,
you know,
also you know how good it feels to write
something new and eventually get it to
the point where you could say it,
Gilbert Gilbert live this hilarious,
right?
So like,
but for years,
like he's gotten out of it now,
but for years he wouldn't update as
material and I took him,
my sister and my brother in law and John
Stamos,
we all went to see him at Caroline's
when Gilbert's up there.
Let's just like three years ago doing
like Calista flockhart
can you not even update and we're just
dying.
And by the way like stainless is
criticizing him.
He's like whispering in my ear.
I heard that five years ago,
I heard that tenure.
I go,
you're on Broadway doing Chicago
30 or 40 50 year old play,
what are you talking about?
But.
So I defended Gilbert,
but I did like I did talk to Gilbert and
Dara and like,
like Gilbert,
you're too funny to,
to not evolve like your first hitting
your prime as a comedian.
And now to his credit he's like on
another level he's just,
that's great though,
that you've inspired them to start
running again.
I embarrassed him to start writing
again.
That's fucking great.
But he,
when he's with us,
like when that thing I said to Jeff,
I go,
if we ever tour again,
we have to bring him on some of these
cakes because he really does like he was
the third element of this,
this whatever chemistry of the thing
that really did for me at least I always
knew that like if it wasn't going
anything with me and Jeff and that's the
truth of it too.
And people will see that in the show
that there's,
you know,
there's a couple of bits that go
nowhere,
but we left them in to show people that
it's real and all that kind of stuff.
But what about getting norm?
Did you guys do anything with Doris?
I wish we could do something with norms
kind of thing on Netflix.
Yeah.
But
he was in the,
in La.
We were in New York and another dude,
he's so God damn,
I wish you would normally stand up.
I'm not saying we will,
but if we ever do this again,
this pumping MC state,
we should get norm.
Did you see his tweets,
his Thanksgiving tweets?
No.
Once again,
on my flip phone friends,
I retweeted it.
He's just so ridiculous,
man.
So funny.
There's something about norms,
just like his ability to,
uh,
you know,
I have this thing about timing.
I don't know what you think about it,
but it was like there's something about
that timing that like,
you know,
I know in today's world that people
don't care about that.
It's more about identity and all that
stuff,
but like norm is a master of timing.
He really is like a master of timing and
this whole thing that he's trying to do
is finding these classic jokes.
I love that.
No,
he's genius.
He's,
he's one of the road gigging
opening for norm.
Really probably road gig ever.
Nineteen 91.
Maybe.
I'm a catch Princeton somehow.
I talked my way into an MC spot and rich
vos was the middle and norm was normally
normally the only famous for doing a few
late night shows whatever.
Wasn't Letterman at the time.
What was the other one?
Uh,
was it thick of the night or something?
Or Bob Costas?
No,
it was,
it was a leader with Bob costs.
It wasn't as cool as that.
Even bill boggs,
it was going to give you some some show
you'll remember in a few minutes and you
go,
oh yeah,
like syndicated whatever it was,
but like I meet norm and he's catch
prints them and he'd do an hour to 45
minutes every show.
He either destroyed or he got zero lasts
for 45 minutes and whenever he got zero
laugh,
he would stand by the door and say
goodbye to people as they left.
Oh,
that's great.
And if he killed,
he would go back up to the room with
Boston and we would play poker like he
was.
He was still up for us.
And then while we were there last,
he got booked on Letterman for the first
time and I had a jeep.
My sister bought me a jeep,
but the money she got from a car
accident and I drove to norm the best.
Hi Robin.
And I drove.
I drove norm to his letter taping his
first letter.
That's incredible.
Cool.
I learned a lot that week.
That's what a great guy to have.
The first guy opened for them.
It was so funny.
That's amazing.
Todd Barry was so obsessed with norm.
He came out and flipped on my bed.
First Guy I ever opened for was a guy
named Warren.
Mcdonald's is really funny,
like old school veteran Boston comic,
but the second guy opened for was Lenny
Clarke.
Atlanta Clark gave me advice that was
totally contrary to his brother's
advice,
but he's Mike Clark,
who's the best,
nicest guy.
I love Mike.
He helped me.
He's.
He's fucking awesome.
My book me back when nobody would book
me when I was just starting out,
but he
was.
When I opened for lenny goes,
he goes,
kid,
you have funny,
but you're too fucking dirty.
He said,
yeah,
you just told me like,
yeah.
He was like,
you should kind of clean your act up,
and then Lenny Clarke came off stage.
He goes,
whatever you do,
don't clean your act up until them kid.
He gave me great advice.
That's strong.
Those two guys than Isis there.
So Boston too.
When I was going to be used into the
core and when I.
When I was preparing a roast of the
Boston cops and Mike really helped me,
like warm up,
got me a bunch of local gigs in the
Boston flavor.
Oh beautiful.
For the Irish people,
Italian people,
it's a good place to do comedy,
man.
That is definitely of the two towns I'm
thinking right now.
Boston and Philly are the two towns that
have changed dramatically.
Comedically.
And also just in terms of like,
like when you walk around in Boston now
you're not like,
Hey,
I'm going to get jumped,
you know,
because I'm wearing a Yankee,
if anything it's like,
you know,
everybody here is so like metro and you
know,
someone's gonna invite me to like a
poetry reading at a,
at a wine bar or something like that.
It's very metro and the comedy there was
still good,
but it's funny,
that old Boston was such a challenge.
It really was like,
especially the outsiders.
What year did you start going,
going into next?
In their nineties,
you know,
and every time it dreaded it.
Yeah,
they really were.
They were,
they were battles every time
and they had local headliners that could
destroy you.
The greatest comics ever offstage.
It was,
it was definitely one of those things.
You were terrified what you would hear
just like,
hey,
you know what,
I'm a Giana.
I don't know what to tell you about.
Um,
Gavin might come down like he just wants
to do a few minutes.
Yeah.
They would go on stage just to fuck with
you.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
And I,
back then,
I don't know if it's still like that for
people starting out,
but comics were me,
but that was their town and they and
they,
and they saw you coming into their town
and they were like,
you know,
you better,
you better prove it.
You know,
it's like before step up revolution,
you had a,
you had to own and never hold grudges.
I don't know why.
I'd never people who were Douchey to me
in the beginning,
I'm like,
I don't know.
It wasn't ready for your response.
Respect.
I'll learn it eventually.
That's a great attitude.
But Hackett to that,
to me once,
he said,
when you're holding a grudge together,
guys out dancing,
it's a great piece of waste energy.
You know,
there was a horrible Hackett though
going on.
What was going on back then was a famine
mentality and I don't think we have that
anymore.
I think that famine mentality is gone
because now everybody realizes that with
the Internet there's,
there's literally an unlimited amount of
viewers and people that could come to
your gigs and it's way more beneficial
for them to know that you,
if you're talking about someone that's
really good for them to know,
you have good.
Like
if Dave says,
oh,
you gotta.
See Jeff Ross is fucking hilarious
comedian.
And I go,
well,
I love Dave,
so he must be right.
You know what I'm saying?
And this is,
this is,
this is the not having a famine
mentality.
That's the thing that fucked us back in
the early days,
like in Boston,
it was before my time because when I
came along,
they had already started.
Steven Wright had been on,
was he on Letterman?
Jay Leno had already taken off and he
was on Letterman all the time.
Those guys had already broken through to
tv,
but there was a sense that some of them
had that like,
where's mine?
Like,
how come I didn't salute?
Yeah,
there was a tiny amount of slots.
It's not like Steven Wright couldn't go
on Letterman.
He'd say,
Hey,
you think I'm funny?
You got to see this Guy Lenny Clarke,
or you gotta.
See this Guy Don Gavin are you got to
see Steve Sweeney.
All these murders that he came up with
and they were all like,
where's mine?
Like,
what the fuck
you just like in my head to have too few
spots,
but also like we're of the generation
and that's not to make this like a whole
like trip to the museum,
a comedy,
but we're of the generation where we
actually saw people who crush a room,
like crush room.
Like today.
I was like,
oh,
you killed it.
You crushed it.
But like seeing Richard Jenny at his
height,
like,
hey caroline's,
or something like that.
Crushed that room.
People leaving exhausted where it's like
two hours in.
You're like,
oh,
he hasn't even hit his this thing yet,
and he's like,
he'll get off the stage.
He's like,
ah,
what did you think of that tag?
I'm like,
which?
dude,
you like throw like a million jokes up
there.
I would watch that and be like,
oh my God,
that's terrifying to see.
It was like watching a wave come at you,
and it was like what people consider now
killing a room or crushing a room.
Like I never got to see Sam Kennison or
any of those people live,
but I assume that was the same thing of
where people could not breed.
They leave the room,
like just going like,
Oh man,
I'm just like exhausted.
I got to see Kennison.
But I didn't get to see him until after
he released his HBO special and after he
released his hbo special,
all that material was gone.
Like what I would've wanted to see was
that because that was like a culmination
of 10 years of doing standup and then
boom,
he does that hbo special and it's just,
I'm a murderous nuclear missile that's.
But I saw him after that.
What year was that?
He did the HBO because I wonder what
year when I saw,
I think it was either 85 or 86.
I think it was 86,
so five plummet.
Rascal for the sold out show and I was
in college and I knew how funny he was.
He was probably already famous old.
Was He at rascals?
Wouldn't be doing a bigger venue by the
guests.
You're right,
because I remember it felt like a
special event.
I saw him at theaters.
I saw him at a couple of big places.
I saw him at one place down the Cape.
It was,
I want to say it was like if I had a
guest today,
I would say somewhere around 2000 seats
and I saw him at great woods,
which is considerably larger than that
and that's right after his hbo special
and this is 80.
This is 86.
80 seven.
Wow.
It's like a work of great words.
Did you shut the fuck up?
I was.
I worked for Wbur,
the the public radio station and I would
record classical music concerts as a.
As a.
As an engineer.
They called it Tanglewood or something.
What'd they call?
Great Woods.
You have a great woods and Mansfield.
Yeah.
I was a security guard there that have
been weird.
If you're better than linkedin.
How did you guys.
I was reluctant security guard because I
would always bring a Hoodie with me and
if shit went down I'd cover up my
security jacket and get the fuck out of
dodge that you'd throw in.
I brought,
brought a Hoodie with me.
I have to like my first couple of days
in the job,
the first day on the job,
there's a dude named alley cat.
He was a dude who ran the security.
They caught some drunk kid who stole a
golf cart,
so they chased him down,
tackled him,
and he was beating him in the face with
a walkie talkie.
That was day one and I was like,
oh right.
It's one of these jobs and it was a.
and I'm not a big person.
I'm five foot eight outside the fight
looking in.
Yes,
exactly.
Right.
So and back then I was competing so I
was only like 160 pounds.
I was really lightens,
I was not getting any tangles with some
big giant drunk dudes.
I'm like,
fuck for 20 bucks an hour or whatever
I'm getting,
so it just bring a Hoodie with me and
when Shit went down it would zip up and
one day shit went down a neil young
concert and they wow.
During the Neil Young concert,
the back area is all grass and they
started bonfires.
These fucking crazy neil young fans
through a bunch of shit on the ground.
Just started fires and then they started
trying to break up these fires and
people were pushing security guards and
then my friend Larry,
who was like the nicest guy in the
world,
punch this guy in the stomach and I'm
like,
okay,
that's it.
If Larry's punching people,
like he's the nicest guy,
but like these people are crazy.
I put the fucking Hoodie on and I'm out.
I just walked straight to my car and
drove the fuck home.
I didn't realize paycheck,
nothing.
I'm like,
I'm out.
Full blown riot.
Two dudes were throwing down and piles
of people beating the shit out of each
other.
There was fires,
they canceled the concert,
they shut the concert in the middle of
what's happening for Nila.
Who is the opener?
That was the problem.
It was the,
it was,
there was two problems sometimes when
you were in the back area where the
grass was,
the acoustics weren't so good.
So like when people went to see comics
it was bad.
It's not good.
Like maybe they fixed the sound,
but back then it was a big issue you had
inside the canopy to hear what the fuck
was going on.
What do you think
a odd ball in like outdoor comedy,
what do you think of that?
I've done some outdoor things.
I did a big outdoor place in Kansas City
this year and it was really fun.
It was really an awesome.
Yeah.
But it was a summer night,
you know,
it was beautiful.
We got lucky with the rain.
There was no rain or anything
when Jeff and I did,
uh,
the odd ball,
like we went on together.
That was my most fun doing the odd ball
thing and I always thought it was a
great.
Like jeff was a super cool to comics and
everything like that.
Like the only guy I've ever seen,
like actually looked like he's having a
great time with Chappelle doing it.
Like I really like.
He's so comfortable everywhere.
But like in the outdoor venue,
you know,
he's taking his time and there's a club.
Yeah.
Like I,
I,
it's just amazing to watch them do it.
But the outdoor thing with the kid never
here,
you know,
like the joke going off into outer
space.
That definitely is,
is,
is something that um,
you know,
even the theater in the round,
which is one I saw Rodney Dangerfield,
they when I was like 17 and that was
another situation where this guy is just
like crushing,
crushing,
crushing and the room cannot breathe,
that kind of thing.
And I was like,
this isn't in the round,
you know?
I was like,
wow,
that's weird.
You know,
I was 17.
I was like,
wow,
is this how it goes?
Like,
you know,
why is he circling around like that?
Is that,
is that part of it?
You know,
I didn't understand that it was in the
round,
you know,
but that,
but now I realize that that's another
like really hard venue to play is the
round,
you know?
Yeah.
I've only done a few of those.
Uh,
did the,
uh,
that place in Phoenix.
That one's in the round Hollywood
theater.
That's a,
that's a great.
Oh,
I know that you did one of his hps was
there and because George Carlin did one
right?
I think so,
yeah.
He did so many of them,
like I did them everywhere.
I mean every year that is bananas.
That's one of the craziest places ever.
And talk about someone who did it
totally differently.
He would basically write a monologue.
Right.
You know,
it's,
take us out,
work at it at all,
not working out,
kind of tightened it up on stage.
They would say,
you know,
as you know,
the bits as you would just keep doing
them and figure out a better way to do
them,
but write it,
write the whole thing.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
And he did it every year.
Wow.
That was like at the height of that hbo
comedy thing,
you'd like tune in specific just to see
national.
Well he was in a different place than
anybody else because of how prolific he
was and some some would say like,
yeah,
but some of it wasn't my favorite stuff
and like listen,
it is impossible to write an hour every
fucking year and have it your best
version of that hour.
You need more time a lot of the times.
But he had an honor.
That commitment of getting the special
right,
but what he did was he did something
that was slightly different than comedy
either because it was even because it
was like a lot of it was like a state of
the union,
a state of civilization.
The state wasn't just comedy.
It's like here's a really wise old guy.
He was super smart but he has some
really good points and he's going to do
this every year.
So it was,
it was,
it was different.
It was more that it wasn't like he never
worked out in clubs.
Like I went to see him once and he was.
He had this whole bit about fuck
everything.
It was like basically fuck this and fuck
that,
and part of it was comedy clubs.
He's like,
they say,
George,
you got to work out.
You're shitting comedy.
He fuck comedy clubs.
Really?
I saw him years later the store.
I mean it was just fucking around.
That's when I knew I'd made it.
I was at the Improv back in the day and
I was probably going on at 2:00
AM and I still have it.
It was a schedule that had George Carlin
going on 30 for like five hours later.
I went onto the prom show or something,
but Carlin came into the Improv.
I got to say hi to
him in the back patio.
The store just.
Hi,
how you doing?
Nice to meet you.
Yeah.
I was like,
wow.
I saw him at the Aspen comedy festival
with comics.
Oh sorry.
Yeah,
no,
he,
he definitely.
So hang on with comics necessarily.
Right?
I remember once like he kinda like just
the friars club.
He's like,
I don't want to hang with the older guys
I want to.
It was weird.
I saw them at the Aspen comedy festival
and he was like,
not doing anything,
like,
you know,
he had like substance stuff going on and
it was like he was treated himself to
one glass of wine a day,
but you know,
how like up to the brim,
like it's one of those where it's like,
hey,
you see like sipping on it,
you know,
like,
and he's looking at me like,
hmm,
you know,
like,
he's like,
oh,
he's a new comic.
He's a big,
you know,
I'm like,
hello,
Mr Carlin.
And he's like,
hmm.
And back to the sipping on this one
glass of wine a day.
I love that.
Well he,
he,
he got injured right hand the pain pill
problem.
Oh Daddy.
So many fucking people,
man.
He was a hardcore guy too.
Well,
yeah,
he did a lot of that back in the day.
But I think the uh,
pain pills was later on in his life and
he just said,
reached a point where he realized I've
got an issue.
I've got to stop this.
But he,
he,
I respect that he really committed to
his craft and you know,
maybe he was trying to do other stuff
here and there because he did a few
acting things,
but that was not his thing.
His thing was hbo specials every year.
Well,
no,
no one else was doing there.
You figure out what your thing is.
Lucky happened.
Yeah.
Well his thing was always,
you know,
having a brilliant social point with
humor attached to it.
That was his thing.
Like some of his best bits were just
like really good points about hypocrisy
and the ridiculousness of our
civilization with like really good
punchline.
He would write to a subject.
Does that too.
He also like a religion.
He was like the first guy to really like
him and Bill Hicks I always thought were
like,
you know,
that was so cool.
Their takes on religion,
you know?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
Lenny Bruce obviously opened that door
that opened the door and it was a pain
in the ass to get used to Tommy about
lenny bruce.
And he was just a pain in the ass.
They got everybody in trouble all the
time.
There'd be cops,
comedy clubs and Shit.
You can't be that guy unless you're a
pain in the ass.
I mean,
he was arrested multiple times.
So what do we have that bad words like?
I like.
Yeah,
yeah.
I think.
I don't think we need a guy like him in
a sentence like crowded,
difficult guy if you live today,
right?
You know,
I mean if he was alive today,
he would just be a great comic.
He wouldn't,
he wouldn't have to do all the shit that
he had to do.
Like if there was,
it's hard for us to.
Whenever you go back and listen to stuff
like lenny bruce,
it's really almost impossible unless you
live through it that time yourself in
that time to put it.
That's why like I can kind of put myself
back in the eighties.
I can kind of remember vaguely.
I have a sense of what it was like.
I can kind of tell you,
I don't have goddamn clue as
to what it was like in the sixties and
so when he was doing this,
we have to put it in context that there
was no,
there was no freedom.
You couldn't say certain words,
you couldn't talk.
Yeah,
I mean really crazy restrictions on the
way people talked and they brought him
into court over and over and over again.
Essentially bankrupt them.
He couldn't work anymore and by the end
he just died of heroin on the fucking
bathroom floor and then he became a mess
and a lot of him bms was him dealing
with his court cases like he's got.
There's recordings of him where he's
going on stage with his legal papers.
Just reading the diversity of the
audience.
He lost his fucking mind,
but we also came up in a club system and
I consider myself a club comic.
Like that's what I do.
That's what I'm supposed to do.
But like these guys were before,
like you say,
Hackett and all these guys way before
the club system,
they played the catskills.
They played some,
you know,
a Jewish camp somewhere,
they did that kind of thing that was
there,
like proving ground and I'm sure that
was probably the hardest of the hardest
gigs to do.
You know,
it's like,
it's an all ages show.
It's,
you know,
there may be a late show where they get
to be a little saucier,
but you know,
it really is a tough thing and it's the
same crowd for a whole week.
I mean honestly,
you know,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
So like I give it up to those guys like
Joan rivers who I think also is like an
unsung hero comedy.
Like she,
she's like,
crosses over that thing from like TV
comedies becomes like a big deal.
Like where you see them on like a Johnny
Carson,
all that kind of stuff.
Like I love her sets.
I watched them one.
Yeah,
she really was a great joke writer.
She was really young.
Savage
to.
She'd go after it.
Well,
who else stayed relevant and they're at
80 years old.
Who else had new material at 80?
No,
but it's really just those two.
Just Carlin and her.
I guess so,
right?
I mean,
who else?
And she died trying to improve her
voice.
Her instrument,
like she was still staying in it.
Sad one.
I was at her funeral.
It was a really amazing.
It was like a king died.
She was the greatest.
She had some serious fucking horsepower
when it came to like her ability to
deliver punchlines and one of the best
books I ever read.
Young comics out there read,
enter talking by Joan rivers about her
early days in stand up and acting.
It's really don't read ladies and
gentlemen,
Lenny Bruce will start putting foil over
your windows and shooting up.
I,
I did read that.
It's a great book.
So I started,
I took a comedy class in New York who
was teaching Lee Frank,
buddy of mine.
He's asking his writing and I was fat
loser living in New Jersey with my
grandfather and my buddy said,
hey,
take this comedy class.
I think you'd be good at it.
I go,
what?
They think,
yeah,
I think you'd be good at it.
And I thought,
well,
it's near the bus station where I would
go to work.
And then go visit my grandpa and take
care of him.
He was sick and and I would just go to
this class for three hours.
It was like a way to socialize really.
I didn't have a desired.
I didn't even know what stand up was,
but the first assignment was to memorize
a comedian's act and do it just for the
class.
Just to get a sense of timing and what
it was like.
We understood it wasn't our material.
It wasn't about that at all.
And I didn't.
I had heard Lenny Bruce was the coolest.
So I went to the springfield public
library.
I took out a lenny bruce that live at
Carnegie Hall Double Album.
I still have it and I remember I had
this routine and I didn't get it the
that the class didn't get it.
And I realized like God,
context is everything.
It just didn't make.
It just wasn't funny.
It didn't hold up at all.
It made almost no sense to me.
So I realized that it really is,
like you were saying before,
Dave,
like the moment the tide isn't the
experience of being there.
People were so restricted back then in
terms of their access to information in
terms of the way they talk to each other
that anything outside of the norm,
anything being broadcast,
and we have to also remember that
broadcasting itself was only like 40 or
50 years old,
so this is a fairly new medium.
Right,
and anything that was even remotely just
outside of what the ics excepted
standard operating were behaving was was
considered decadent and racy enlists
dirty lenny.
They would.
He would talk about things that you're
not supposed to talk about that.
Yeah,
the taboo subjects,
but today that same stuff has already
been.
He opened the door,
Richard Pryor kicked it down,
lit it on fire.
Eddie Murphy nuclear bombed it and then
it kept going on Kennison and Hicks and
it's those.
There's nothing there anymore.
There is no shame in any of these
subjects anymore.
You can't.
There's no built in weirdness to it that
he experienced back then and he would've
never been able to do comedy any
differently.
I think that's also what we need to
understand as if like Eddie Murphy went
back to 1960 and did his same kind of
material that he did in Ra,
they wouldn't take,
it wouldn't,
everybody would be like,
he's yelling at us like,
what is he doing?
This is not comedy.
Like they wouldn't be ready for it
there.
There's these stages that have to happen
and I think you kind of have to have a
guy like lenny who's a spelling it out
for people and then a guy like Carlin
takes it to a different place and then
uh,
and then they just keep going and prior
comes along and introduces this
incredible honesty to it.
It's like each comic had one less layer
of exposition in there as almost like
they opened for each other
decade or by five years most.
Right.
So interesting.
And Kennison,
when kinison came around,
it was the first time that I'd ever saw
something and went,
oh,
well,
that the comedy can be anything.
Yeah.
Because I thought that comedy was these
guys who would go on the tonight show
because that's mostly what I'd see where
they would go to.
You ever notice and they will be talking
about stuff they noticed and I loved it.
I would love standup comedy,
but I never.
I never thought that standup comedy was
anything like Kennis.
And when I saw Kenneth for the first
time I was like,
oh,
this is a totally different thing.
Like this guy's doing a totally
different thing.
Like this is crazy.
He's still going to enter anxious
monologue when he was standing in front
of a guy going,
you know,
you look at this face,
you didn't marry.
Look at this stage.
I was married twice.
I was married for two fucking years old.
No,
but nobody had ever done anything like
that before.
And I remember thinking at that time
like,
wow,
comedy is really fascinating because it
can be so many different things,
but you also want it to be a rockstar.
So rockstar,
but that.
But when you see all those great things
that he could do,
like his staged craft,
I guess you would call it,
the things he could do,
he could really hold the stage.
And in today's world where it's pretty
much everyone's located,
that's Kinda like the new style of like
low key whatever like that.
That to me always was like,
he was like a force of nature.
That's what I was like.
It was like this guy.
Like somebody opened the door in a
hurricane came in.
She knows.
I love that.
He has something very seriously in
common.
Roseanne,
yeah.
They both experienced significant head
injuries at a young age.
From then on became this new person.
Roseann had the exact same story.
She got hit by a car that she got fucked
up.
She was in a mental hospital for nine
months.
I mean really bad.
So when,
when people talk about Roseanne and say
bad things about him,
like you really are doing,
I didn't know that everyone a disservice
by expressing this the way you're doing
it because you're not even taking into
consideration everything she does.
You should take into consideration.
She had a significant brain,
a massive trauma to the brain when she
was 15 years old,
right.
Her head bounced off of the fender of a
fucking car.
She was laid out.
She was in a coma.
She was in a mental institution for nine
months after that.
Like this is like asking someone who has
broken legs to not limp.
Even when you are asking.
Even when you.
I heard you talked to her about it.
She almost like skipped over it as if it
was something she didn't really want to
address.
And you were like backtracked.
She had I,
I had to get it out of her because this
is what I know about her and she,
she knows that I'm a giant fan.
Like she knows.
I always say if you have to list like
top 20 comics of all time,
Roseanne is 100 percent in there and
probably one of the most important ones
because what she did when she first got
on Hbo,
when she first,
when people first start,
she would,
first of all,
she would fucking murder domestic on it.
She would murder and she.
She had a totally different style.
Her,
she didn't give a fuck like when she was
up there as a first time you saw a woman
who was like aggressive and insulting
and didn't give a fuck.
Didn't give a fuck what she looked like,
didn't give a fuck what you thought
about what she looked like.
She was just there to be funny and she
knew that I had that,
that opinion ever when she did the show.
So it helped.
It helped.
Like I'm not trying to hurt you in any
way and I just want people to understand
who you are.
She's a fucking bunch of different psych
medicines,
man.
They've got her on all kinds of crazy
shit trying to move it around.
And then on top of that she's taken and
she's drinking and like everybody relax.
Leave that poor lady alone like you're
going after when she's in her sixties
for a fuck up on twitter.
You thinks that that lady looks black is
lying.
You're either full of shit.
Like if you didn't know if I said okay,
you don't know anything about her,
what's the ethnicity?
You'd be like,
Oh,
a boy,
right.
You know,
I've got,
I,
I saved the picture on my phone in case
I get into conversation with people
about it because it's such a.
because it's one of those things where
nobody wants to look like they are in
any way racist,
right?
No one wants to look at their racist.
Right?
I don't want to,
but you also have to be honest,
doesn't mean you're racist.
If you look at that and go thought that
was saying that Herman,
she could be a lot of things.
She could be a lot of things.
She has long,
straight hair or not long,
short,
straight hair like she can be a lot of
things.
This is not obvious for you.
Say that.
It's obvious you're being disingenuous.
I can't talk to you because you're not
being.
You're not realistic.
This is not obvious.
It shouldn't be tweeting about politics
and middle of the night on ambient.
Well,
she also shouldn't be tweeting about
lizard people or any other crazy shit.
She tweets about trails and right
before her Cheryl,
when she went from comedy to her show
and once again it was uh,
you know,
uh,
like her act was her show and like that
was one thing that like since her,
everybody was always like,
you know,
you got to like throw out in your act
like 20 minutes about like what you are
and who you think the sitcoms should be.
And it was like,
it didn't work as well for anybody else
except for her because that really was
her life.
And it was her thing like Ray Romano was
another guy was really good at that
where he would put up,
you know,
his act.
He's really great joke writer too.
He was like totally like had these great
jokes about his family and his wife and
the expectations of their relationship.
And then that became the essence of that
show so that you see,
like everybody,
you remember that it was definitely a
decade of like agents going like,
hey,
you gotta get like,
you know,
did you have a dog growing up?
Do a joke about that you.
And get a sitcom going on there.
I went through all that shit when they
were trying to do sitcoms around people
and they would try to get you to put
together like some sort of a theme and
do it on stage for a sitcom.
I'm seeing guys specifically craft and
act that they thought was going to get
12 minutes.
Yup.
Yes.
People got seriously into it,
man.
It became like a different thing.
It's like a goal.
The goal was the Sitcom.
The Lachlan was another one.
Did you like those days acting?
I got lucky.
Okay.
I got super lucky.
I got super lucky first of all,
I'd never had my own show.
All right.
So never had to carry anything.
And then two,
I did a really shitty one.
First a one that should have been really
funny,
but then too many people got involved
and it got too convoluted and fucked up
and it just didn't work.
And that show got canceled.
And then I got lucky that I got on a
show that was already.
They already did the pilot,
when I came onto news radio,
Ray Romano was supposed to do the
pirate,
the pilot rather he gets fired.
They hired a new guy and then they
filmed the pilot and then after they
filmed the pilot,
they got rid of the new guy and then I
came in that.
So there was a,
there was a lot of steps.
So you jumped the hard part of jumped
off it and I.
But I mean creatively,
there's no way you found that
fulfilling.
Maybe at the time of news radio was
unusually free in how much you could
create.
You could constantly.
Paul sams is a genius and the nicest guy
in the world and he would let you,
like,
he would just use no ego whatsoever.
The Best Shit.
Like he would let Dave Foley was
constantly rewriting jokes and
constantly introducing new punchlines.
So he,
he,
he was like,
you know,
probably one of,
if you look at all the punchlines that
had ever been on the show,
I'll like a percentage of them you would
attribute to date photo,
like a significant percentage.
It's genius,
but they would let them do it.
They wanted everybody to do that.
They wanted only job where you want to
do more than you're supposed to do and
you're like mad if he did all that.
Well,
there was eight people in the show too.
It's a lot of human beings to be talking
for 22 minutes and of course Phil was
the star.
Phil Hartman was.
He was so talented.
That guy super talented.
He.
He was also super professional.
I would prepare.
You would have.
He would have a clipboard,
right,
or a notebook with all of his scenes in
there with different colors for the tabs
and he would practice them.
You'd be.
You'd see him sitting there by himself
just going over his lines,
moving his head back and then after.
Yeah.
I mean he was a fucking meticulous
professional.
Like I said,
I'm just saying.
I'm just saying about like some guys,
especially the comics where they go and
they get that,
that microphone.
Oh,
sorry about the comics.
They get the Sitcom and then they ride
it as long as they can and then then
they go back to stand up and we've seen
that,
you know,
you can throw a dart at like a schedule
anywhere in the country and you'll see
that guy and I'm on.
I'm always like,
you know what?
Isn't it sad that you didn't keep doing
the standup because now you're kind of
right back to where you started in terms
of standup.
Like he didn't get to grow that way
apart.
Yeah.
And I don't do it for years and like
everybody's always like,
you know,
this is the best touring time when you
have a sitcom,
but most people don't want to go on tour
like that,
you know?
To me I would be like,
yeah,
you're right.
Let's get out there.
You know,
but well you,
you could do it for a few months,
but yeah,
the schedule
you're filming,
you're going to be stuck at in La.
And then on top of that,
especially back then when you start out
a sitcom,
you're doing 12 hour days until you
figured out how to do it.
True.
Once the show had been figured out by
like season three or four,
we were down to like three days a week,
sometimes four days a week.
Mostly.
Mostly for very rarely five,
unless there was some significant crazy
semination make we did 98 I think.
Wow.
We just did three,
maybe [inaudible] 99,
something like that.
But,
um,
I did a hundred and 48 fear factors.
Wow.
Then I did six more than we did when,
when it came back six or seven more.
I think we did seven but 48.
Yeah.
That was preposterous.
That was when I was losing my mind.
Wasn't even one a day or was it less
than.
Well,
no one took three days.
Sometimes you could bang out one,
two days.
Like you could have the beast on early
in the day and at night,
like the final stone at night.
Um,
you know,
again,
very fortunate.
It was a great gig.
Plenty of money and it was all good.
It definitely helped my standup because
it gave me fuck you money too.
It gave me the ability to not worry
about like having money in the bank
because I'm not,
I don't have like extravagant tastes.
I'm not too ridiculous with money,
but I like feeling like I don't have to
worry.
Like as soon as you don't have to worry
about it.
Okay,
good.
Don't think about that anymore.
Now think about other things.
So it,
it really helped me there and also the
apostrophe of it was a boundless source
of material.
We just such a ridiculous show that
I hosted a spinoff that didn't get
picked up.
What was it called?
Say uncle her.
Her.
What's his show too?
It wasn't and I was right on the man
show and that's how I knew David
Horowitz who was producing fear factor
and they had a show called say uncle.
They try later paranoid in the De Niro
movie.
I wrote the comedian called like stop
uncle or whatever it was.
But anyway,
the big,
one of the big things was a guy,
a contestant got in a Turkey pen and we
put maple syrup all over when he rolled
around in these like birds,
like pecked at him.
And He,
his family's there watching and he
starts bleeding and she and I stopped a
thing and the producers were mad like,
you can't stop in the middle of like the
guy's crying.
I go and it was just a total disaster.
You could tell it was going to be a big
hit,
but it was risky.
And then I remember going to Jimmy
Kimmel's like Premiere Party for Jimmy
Kim alive.
And uh,
I saw the head of ABC,
they're a.
and I'd never done this in my entire
life.
It was like getting a drink.
And I walked over and I said,
please don't pick it up.
It's rough.
It's going to be,
it's going to be too hard to stand
behind really torturing people.
Didn't pick it up,
but he just kinda looked at me and
smiled.
And there's this,
this would've been 2003.
Yeah,
that was right after fear factor was
first launched.
When,
when those shows what happens is you get
used to one thing and so you have to do
something that's bigger and better than
next year.
And so when we came back,
I felt uncomfortable with a lot of the
shit they know how to do it,
like these guys are top of the food
chain.
They.
But they were doing some sketchy shit.
Like one of them we had these people
chained to a tree with a bungee cords
that were attached to a helicopter and
they had to figure out the right locks
to unlock the bungee cord that they're
the straps to keep them to the tree.
And then as soon as they do,
they undo the strap and they go fucking
shooting out into space into the center
of this giant Canyon and they're
bouncing underneath this helicopter.
And I remember thinking like,
this does it.
We could do this a thousand times.
One of them,
someone's going to die.
Of course one of them,
someone's going to die and it might be
the next one.
It never.
We got lucky dude.
I really feel like we got lucky.
I really,
really honestly,
100 percent feel like we got lucky.
There was a few things.
First of all,
there's a certain amount of risk that
you take whenever you're doing anything
like jump your car off of a building
roof,
which we did.
We had people fly cars across a train,
a moving train.
Okay.
There's risk involved in that.
Right?
But the one that scared the shit out of
me the most was bull riding.
We had people ride bulls.
I was the only time I had told
contestants,
don't do it.
I'm like,
if you,
if you want to ask me,
I would say don't do it on air.
No,
no,
no.
Before we go on air.
I mean I gave them the standard,
but when I would talk to them I'd say,
look,
it's up to you,
right?
I mean if you want to go on me,
people do know how to ride bulls,
but you don't know how to ride a bull.
We're not teaching you how to ride a
bull.
You're not going through classes.
You don't have to.
Slowly but surely building up your
techniques.
You're just going to go ride a bull.
Don't do that.
That's what I would say.
And we had this girl,
she was like 98 pounds.
She got launched off the back of this
bowl and she'll do this.
These people went fucking flying that
things kicking fall.
Bear.
Yeah.
Barely misses them when it's kicking.
I mean they're wearing helmets and shit.
But look at this.
Look at this,
look at it.
I mean,
come on man.
Look at this.
I mean that's,
that fall.
The way she felt like that.
That is like getting hit in the back of
the head with the world.
Yeah.
So like my personal feelings about
trauma and about what's dangerous and
shit like this.
This is a no,
no.
Especially for a 90 pound woman.
Like this poor lady.
Oh my goodness.
You got up cute little fellow.
I was back then.
Yeah,
she got up,
man.
She was tough as shit.
But everybody.
I feel like in that one I feel like we
got lucky.
I feel like we've rolled the dice
because if they stop you,
they,
they lacerate livers and crushed.
Crushed.
They can stump you.
The funny thing was those stunk.
Guys are so fucking tough.
Those guys are so used to putting their
ass on the line that they don't think
anything about someone doing something
risky to them.
That's what you do.
You show up for work and
that's definitely a different in your
head like Alpha something.
Animals have to do that to be a fight,
to crave that.
Like a wonder what the family's saying.
Does it keep them from having a family?
There's a wall.
Who's going to marry you if you're
throwing your life in the line unrelated
to war or famine.
I think there's a certain allure to
remember that TV show.
The fall guy.
How about evil knievel?
Women loved him.
Women loved evil knievel.
If that's a good point.
We may love risk takers.
They like bmx,
guys that do those flips and shit and
those guys or those guys really shit.
And now they have the park core guys
were there,
like climb up a building with no.
Any,
any,
uh,
any kind of.
So you could smoke.
You could do park Parkour on a iron iron
grid.
Do you exercise at all day?
I do the kettlebells,
yeah.
You were telling me that.
I'm still doing that.
I can I,
you know,
because I wanted to ask you this off.
The microphone
is like I seem to be getting more out of
pull ups and,
and just regular calisthenics and am out
of the,
out of the Kettlebell experience.
I think it's because like maybe I'm just
more into it now,
you know.
Well there's definitely no better
exercise for you then pull ups and push
ups.
That to me is if I,
if somebody had to save for the rest of
your life,
you gotta pull up bar and no weights.
Yeah.
You know you're going to be okay.
I'd be like,
I'll take that over.
Not having a pull up bar because I think
there's certain amount.
There's certain kinds of workouts when
you manipulate your own body to pushups.
I think too,
because you could vary your pushup
widths and you could do so many things
just with Chin ups and pushups and then
with bodyweight,
like single leg squats and things like
that,
you can get a tremendous workout in with
just a chin up bar.
Yeah.
Body weight and then there's something
about like that.
Do 100 of them,
like I can't even do like 10,
like 10 would be great for me.
But like the guys who can do 100,
it's so hard.
It's almost like torture to do ups.
Chin ups.
You can do 100 chin ups is a fucking
sap.
Yeah.
Like I,
I,
I mean that definitely is the goal.
Do.
Um,
I'll do 100 in two sets.
Yeah.
I don't do it though.
I do sets of 10 and I don't do any more
than 10 and I do them multiple times a
day.
Like I have a chin up bar in my house so
I'll walk in and I'll just jump up and
do 10,
10 and I've found that like the one
thing that's helped my squeeze with
Jujitsu and with being able to pick my
body and just move around better.
It's just,
just do them randomly throughout the
day.
I do chin ups all the time,
like whenever,
like those bars in the back,
I'll do a show here and then I'll go
back and do tension.
I'm like that with masturbation so I can
have sex any time you're ready to go,
ready to go.
But
if I had to pick one thing,
it would be that it'd be a chin up bar
and then bodyweight stuff,
you could do that for sure.
That's not into the kettle bells
on the,
on the road.
It's hard to do,
you know,
like I don't like go into the hotel gym
or anything like that.
I like to keep it in the room so
sometimes you jump rope or something
like that.
But I would say I've gotten in better
shape,
but I still feel like,
you know,
um,
crap most of the time.
But uh,
when I was a kid when I was a kid,
like it was all that stuff like pushups
and sit ups and all that kind of stuff.
And now that I'm back to it,
I'm like,
you know,
I forgot how great this is.
You know,
it's really cool.
what's a great thing for the pull ups
afterwards?
Those trx things.
Oh yes.
Now my trainer was
to the door of the hotel room and you
could do all these crazy exercises and
it's real small.
You can just tuck it in your bag.
I love that.
I love the hotel room.
Like we've all seen that in the movie,
the assassin doing a couple,
a couple of very slow pushups.
Sometimes if I go down to a gym and
there's nothing that I want to do in
there,
I'll work out my hotel room.
You,
you never were like a runner.
Were you like a run now?
But it's only been over the last couple
of years really.
But even when you were like doing a
taekwondo,
right?
Never had much.
I thought that was part of their thing.
They had like a military kind of feel to
it.
Definitely
a military feel to it and some,
some different.
Uh,
they would call it Dojo gangs.
You know,
Jeff's a black
bow tie.
No,
we are actually on the show.
He pulls out the nunchucks.
That's not a part of it,
but that's okay.
You know,
I'm rusty.
I have to admit I need to get back to
you exercise these days.
I've been doing a little bit of Yoga but
honestly I've been doing a lot of not
exercising lately.
Like feel good.
Like I'm going a place now where I need
to start exercising again.
We talked about this in the parking lot
the other day.
Right.
But on a standup hiatus and when I'm not
performing I don't care as much about my
instrument and I've been editing and
writing and producing so I don't know.
I've gotten a little not late I guess
lazy and I don't feel as good.
Like I know I recognize it in my body so
I need to snap out of it.
I think he needs,
it's like a,
like a,
like a group or like people to hang with
because you know,
that would make it more fun going out by
myself.
Yeah.
If there was like a.
If there was like a group of guys,
you know,
come on man,
don't let us down.
You could find like a crossfit class to
join or some shit like that.
I mean they always have those kinds of
things.
There's all sorts of different classes
that you know is awesome.
I've done one of those high intensity
interval training things at a yoga place
to whether you do some yoga and some
like really light weights,
but all these crazy little exercises.
That's fun too.
You got a dancer pose.
We doing.
Let me see me say.
Oh,
you trying to do that?
Don't hurt yourself.
Yes.
Oh that is that what it's called?
Standing bow thing.
It's called standing bow and there's
this one.
Keep it going.
What are you going?
No one can see you.
You're supposed to grab both legs,
but that's okay.
Do it.
Grab that other leg.
Bet You got it.
Nope.
This is really do.
Come on son.
Here he goes.
Nice.
And the headphones on.
Take it to the new level.
It's like a NASA mission called again,
a cry for help.
The crab.
So when you,
when you say you do yoga,
like how often do you do it?
What I would go,
I would go to hot yoga.
You go a couple times a week are now I
just kind of do it in my backyard to
stretch out after a long flight or
something.
That's good.
Anything kind of like you had the tank
like that's a time to think about life.
To think through it.
Think through a mission that you're
working on.
Some family issue.
It's like quiet.
You're.
It's about you.
For me,
Yoga,
it's like giving yourself a massage.
It's more gratifying than going to glory
awaits and stuff.
Stretch out before sets.
You ever do that?
Stretches before you go do set feels
real good.
There's something about that that's very
relaxing.
Puts you in a good.
I think you carry around.
When you're tight,
you carry around a lot of tension that
you don't necessarily want.
Pigeon pose.
That's where all the tension is.
That's the one where your.
Where your leg comes under
your.
I want to ask what the fuck is he doing?
Oh Wow.
Jeff,
that.
Oh,
I've seen this one.
Yeah,
I've seen that one.
That's called a hip opener.
Yeah.
Good.
That good hips,
Bro.
It looks so sad.
That's one.
Like if you go to your yoga,
people will do that pose and start
crying because there's so much emotion
and anxiety release from the hitch.
That's not real job.
You're just crying because someone tells
you you should cry.
Sit.
Do you want to be a part of this group
cry nonsense.
They always want to say that this is
opening up your colon.
You don't have any fucking.
There's no diagrams.
You don't know where the colon is like,
you better stop.
You better stop saying that you don't
have any fucking.
There's tension in the hip.
Cat Scans.
What's that stuff called?
Magnetic residence Mris.
You don't have that Brown.
You don't have any real evidence.
There's emotion.
Who should lead a bowl of me?
What?
I was just thinking about my dad much
get the fuck out of here with that shit.
You're not.
You don't have any memories specifically
and people say,
no,
but when I'm in that position and they
tell you that it's an if emotions come
out here,
you just let them like what emotions
cut out.
You've been hypnotized.
Someone told you our mission to be
emotionally vulnerable.
Yes,
that that in hypnosis and you don't get
that eating lunch at a deli or working
out with the boys in the gym.
If you're at a quiet,
dark yoga place with other people that
are staring at their own at the floor,
right.
You can relax a little emotionally.
That's a logical definition.
That's a logical way of explaining
what's really going on.
I'm going to stay.
It's just good to hear.
Let me ask you a question.
Do you eat before you go on stage?
No.
Me Neither.
This guy has to eat like he asked.
He eat before he goes on stage like
right before,
like pretty much right before.
I mean I don't think there's anything
wrong with eating some fruit right
before you go up on stage,
but for me,
I don't want to.
There's a certain amount of resources
your body is going to use for digestion.
That's just a fact.
There's a reason why fighters don't eat
a fucking car.
You can mash potatoes,
right?
I hate that fight because your body will
be like,
fuck you dude.
We got to digest this stuff and it
sloshed around your stomach.
It gets in the way.
I hate it.
Obviously this.
I know plenty of people who have to eat.
Sometimes I in that first episode of our
show,
I eat during the show,
I ordered Mozzarella sticks to the
stage.
That's how hungry I was by the late
show.
There's nothing wrong with that meant
it's not.
Not to say that you can't do it and for
you you're so casual,
like you're probably better off feeling
good then you are like being,
having more mental alertness.
Slightly out.
Also like being hungry.
Hunger.
I liked it.
There's annoying.
I ate in the car.
Coming to your studio today and the
first thing I said to Jeff Atlanta,
the door,
was there anything to eat around here
because it's
like it's an anxiety thing too,
like before you're going to perform and
I remember reading years and years and
years and years ago that David letterman
would eat pineapple right before he went
on,
so I always ask for pineapple in my
writer's.
Hi Stacy Pineapples,
a good stacy marketing sales.
He'd also would do a fasting and then he
would pick out.
That was his thing.
Let him in.
That's what I heard,
that he would like not eat for like two
or three days and then he would do that
and that's how my friend Russ does it.
Like that kind of thing of like where
you like just basically spartan,
like nothing.
Nothing,
nothing.
And then like you get to eat whatever
you want.
I believe for sure that people eat too
much food and me included,
I eat too much meat
and when I,
when I fast like especially intermittent
fast,
I do like 16 hours at night when I do do
that.
I feel way better.
Way Better.
Wait.
What fascinates between dinner and the
next time I eat is 16 hours.
Jeff,
can you imagine that?
No.
Could you just decide in,
do you go to bed?
Would have to be getting a colonoscopy
or you just look,
you eat dinner,
you'd done it eight.
You go to bed or do whatever the fuck
you do,
but just know more.
How do you.
What are you talking about?
He can't.
Yeah.
You have to eat to come on at 10.
The last thing I want to do is eat any
later than eight.
I go right to the cookies in the back of
the comedy store.
Cookies
are different though.
That's quick.
Carbs.
That actually is not a bad idea.
I see.
That's not a bad idea at all.
Like you don't need that stuff to you.
I'll eat that stuff.
When I was doing this sober October
fitness challenge with Ari and Tom Seger
and Bert Kreischer,
I eat everything in sight.
I ate pizza and cookies.
I eat everything because it's just one
calories,
but the problem with cookies and stuff
like that,
it's like you can eat them,
but you just can't make a habit of
eating them all the time or will fuck
you up.
It's just gonna fuck you up.
When you go on stage,
not a bad idea.
Got a little pick me up.
Energy,
quick carbs.
Your body's going to break down those
carbs.
No Sugar and glucose is a very good fuel
for the brain.
Really works.
Yeah.
Carbs are good for the brain,
especially in like if your body's carb
adapted.
If you eat carbs all the time and you
can eat some carbs right before you go
onstage,
that'll give you like a little energy.
I feel so much better.
Even lift.
Yeah.
Really,
like if you wanted to have a cookie or
maybe even a snickers bar and then lift
weights,
I wouldn't.
I wouldn't say don't do that.
Say that'll give you some fucking sugar
to burn off.
Like it's not the best food for you in
the world,
but you're asking for it for a very
specific reason.
Like after it's over,
I'd say yeah,
go have some salmon and some vegetables
and eat healthy,
but right before you want to work out.
Like you could drink a coke,
like you could drink a coca cola and if
you're going to lift for an hour,
okay,
go ahead.
Drink a coke.
Who gives a shit.
You got to burn that shit off and it's
just going to be fueled.
That you use is.
I wouldn't suggest you do it all the
time,
but it's not going to have a negative
effect on you.
It's really a cumulative thing with
people in diets.
It's eating too much sugar or too much
bullshit for too many days in a row and
not giving your body a chance to relax.
So when I,
when I don't eat,
I never considered like,
oh,
that's lightheadedness.
I'm like,
I'm probably having a stroke.
Right?
This is it.
I should find a place to lay down.
I think that's awesome.
Well listen,
food is fucking phenomenal,
right?
And you're lucky you live in New York
City and then you come to la so you're
in both places and you're in two spots
that have some of the greatest
restaurants on the planet earth.
And if you're like a Foodie,
Foodie,
some cash,
Jeff Ross,
you can go wherever the fuck you want.
I do order a nice bottle of wine and
have a fucking beautiful steak with the
right accoutrements and you know,
why wouldn't you?
I mean it's,
it's a beautiful pleasure and evaluate a
stake.
Some red meat fucker fight.
It's like I'm either on
as soon as I eat a steak and I don't
need them as much as I used to,
but a lot on the tour.
Maybe it was you,
me and Monica.
That was a great.
What was.
What were you guys having?
They're like a porter house,
you know the thing where like not only
at the ribs still there,
but the hubs like that kind of thing.
That really basically like a do it
yourself,
do it yourself kind of steak bone in
real.
We really went to.
Yeah,
we went to town on that.
She'd eat more that I love a good steak.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with it.
I think what's wrong with steak?
What would people think was wrong with
Ron?
With red meat is all the stuff you eat
with it.
All the sugar and bullshit and bread and
pasta and then alcohol and sedentary
life.
There's a bunch of things,
but I think if you're a healthy person
who exercise all the time,
I don't think stakes bad for you at all.
I don't even think a little bit.
I think it's good for you.
I think it's the opposite of bad for
you.
I think all of our preconceived notions
about what's healthy,
all of them vary because some people
that really don't do good with red meat.
Some people don't do well with fish.
People have weird,
but I don't eat fish.
I don't like it either.
Do you eat it?
Love it.
You do that right away,
like steps up your whole game,
right?
That's for sure.
It's a lifesaving thing.
Well,
if you get it,
a lot of those essential fatty acids
that you can get from like an oily fish,
like a salmon,
there's.
They're so good for you,
man.
So good at reducing inflammation.
Do you take fish oil at all?
One of the best things you can take fish
oil,
Krill oil and anything.
Getting those essential fatty acids
which so many people are missing from
their diet.
Just getting a good healthy supply of it
everyday.
It's just good for everything,
man.
It's good for your skin.
It's good for your brain.
Good for muscle development.
Oil.
Yeah.
Official is phenomenal.
It's good for inflammation and if you
have joint aches and stuff like that,
officials have a burger.
I feel like I have a booger,
you know,
how you like touch your nose and it
feels moist and you're like,
what's happening here?
Do you have a cleaner?
What's going on here?
We're good.
I think you're clean.
You're good.
But officials,
just one of the best things,
man.
So good for you.
What does it,
what is fish oil?
Oil extracted from fish and the fish a
little bit of calm.
They,
they,
they excelled.
Merge booth at the Joe.
So because like David,
have you ever
caught it?
Caught like a what?
What is it like a sport?
Fish,
you know,
like a big one or anything like that.
And then you would make steaks out of
that too.
Um,
I've done that with the,
the most delicious thing I think I
caught was a Wahoo other names for it.
So we're,
we caught in Hawaii.
It was phenomenal man,
because big we brought it.
We were staying at a hotel and we
brought it to the,
uh,
the waiter or the chef in the hotel
would cook stuff for you and you would
just bring them to the,
uh,
the fish and,
you know,
he would go,
how do you guys think,
do you want to prepare this?
And so we said,
I don't know,
like,
what do you think?
It's like,
what would you do if somebody brought
you this?
He goes,
I would prepare a bunch of different
ways because there's a huge fish so I
can make you guys a little bit of
[inaudible],
a little bit of Sushi.
My perfect.
So it was,
he cooked it six hours after it was
dead.
I mean we caught it and then six hours
later we're eating it for lunch.
It was insane.
It was so good.
That is cool.
Oh,
that's it right there.
Wow.
That's what it looks like.
There's another name for it.
And the Hawaii,
they call it an oh no.
Oh no,
that's right.
That's right.
It's still licious.
It's so good
fishes looking at the camera too.
Oh wait,
that's crazy.
But yeah,
it's.
You like fishing over hunting?
No,
fishing is harder.
I like them.
Both you do
is way more intense and I feel way worse
for the animal.
Like I don't feel bad for them.
Fish.
Yeah,
exactly.
For whatever reason,
I'm just being honest,
like if I catch a big salmon and I'm
like,
sorry dude,
right,
but this is what I'm here for.
Like,
but when I shoot a deer,
um,
there's always a little part of me and
it's like,
oh,
you know,
this is what I,
I eat and I know that if I don't do
this,
they're going to die of starvation or
disease or they're going to be ripped
apart.
Asshole first by coyotes.
Like this is not a good end for them no
matter what.
And me shooting them,
it's probably the best end they're ever
going to get all those justifications
aside.
It's a different feeling when you see
like an elk down.
Then when I catch a salmon salmon,
it's 100 percent happiness.
But what about when you pull the
trigger?
I'm seeing the animal downs one thing,
but what about knowing it's coming?
It's hard to keep your shit together.
That's a hunter.
That's the hunting.
You get emotional.
No,
you don't.
You get nervous.
You don't want to fuck it up.
You don't want to injure anything.
So there's a lot of anticipation in that
moment.
It's sort of,
it's very intense and uh,
whatever amount of meat you get from
that animal,
whenever you eat it,
you're going to think about that moment.
You think about that moment.
Every time I eat,
let slip while you think about it.
Like this is,
this was a intense life or death moment
in life,
like this circle of life chain moment in
life that I participated in it and now
I'm eating it so I know exactly what the
food is as opposed to going to Morton's
get a nice steak and mashed potatoes.
I don't know where the fuck they grew
that potato.
I get that feeling when I opened the can
of pringles went on Monday when I'm in
the
refrigerator.
Creamsicles do you think,
do you like fishing at all?
I used to fish as a kid and the Hudson
River with my grandfather.
We would catch bass and I really loved
it.
I haven't done it since I was a kid.
Really.
It's fun.
It's a fun thing to do.
It's a passion.
Yeah.
With just if you could find like if
you're doing a gig and you could find a
spot that has like a party boat
especially,
and they.
They'll take out and everybody dunks a
line and people pulling fish left and
right.
Nobody's laughing and people drinking
beers.
It's fucking fun,
man.
It's fun.
Yeah,
but that was a big thing in New England.
We do party boats for bluefish and just
go to a spot and everybody dropped their
line and they'd be pulling these fish up
and then,
you know,
you cook them later that night.
It's fantastic.
Wow.
Just makes you think about what a fish
is too and how weird it is.
We got this alien world connected to us.
We pull these things out,
cut their fucking heads off and cook
them up.
Well,
you've been to Japan and all those
places.
I've been to Japan,
but I fucked up when I was there and I
didn't go to the fish market.
The fish market in Tokyo is one of those
like a million fish.
We don't even know about that.
They liked it.
It's crazy,
but it's so,
so interesting to see like,
you know,
we're so used to,
like you said,
bread and all that stuff.
It's like,
you know,
is it a meal without bread?
It's like these people like go months
without seeing a piece of bread.
Yeah.
They're not in the bread and they're all
thin.
Yeah.
It's hilarious.
They're their noodles.
A lot of times they're rice noodles.
It's very different.
You know,
there's wheat noodles there too though,
right?
They just,
they eat different than us.
They have a completely different style
of eating in just.
It's one of the coolest things about
Tokyo man,
is that it's almost like an alternative
country.
It's,
Oh,
you mean this city because it's so
different.
Like say if you're in Los Angeles,
right?
You'll leave from Los Angeles and you
know you're here in 2018 and you drive
it around.
This is the way people live over here
and this is how people were in traffic
and this is how people are when they
come to the comedy store,
all these different places,
and then you go to Tokyo,
you go,
oh,
wow.
Is also people in 2018 to live in at the
exact same time,
but they're doing it totally
differently.
Like everybody's super polite as you
walked on the street.
There's no people bumping into anybody.
Nobody's yelling at anybody.
They're very polite,
but they're also very Japanese,
right?
The majority of people you see are
Japanese homogeneous,
lightly integrated,
right?
I mean,
there's some,
you see some Africans there.
See some people like us there,
but it's mostly Japanese people.
It's,
uh,
it's interesting to see it.
Have you seen this TV show on Amazon
called the man in the high castle now?
What is it?
It's a future.
It's basically America.
If the Nazis won the war and they
partner with the Japanese and the
Japanese owned California,
Northern California,
and the Nazis on the rest of the country
and the Midwest,
sort of a no man's land.
So New York is Nazi,
New York.
They split it up.
The but,
but Japanese.
Whoa.
It's third season
and I'm obsessed with it.
Philip Dick is the,
uh,
is the PSI writer.
So he's classic.
It's one of his books.
He's the mayor,
he's gracious guy.
That guy has been in a lot of stuff,
was really good.
What is his name?
I forgot it.
The actor's name,
Rufus Rufus.
See?
Well,
is that I say it.
Yeah,
it's really good looking place.
The governor of New York.
Let's see,
food for the Arbor group in proofers.
The governor of New York pure is the
governor of New York.
Yeah.
But it's a very interesting show.
Basically New York cops wearing Nazi
armband.
So there's still New York cops like,
hey,
the furious says I got give you a
ticket.
You know,
it's like that.
And it's fascinating how they do the
show.
But what's interesting about Japanese
culture and the show is you see the,
the,
the fancy class,
the aristocratic class of Japanese of
Japan,
uh,
runs essentially,
um,
San Francisco.
And you see how they're very snobby and
particular in and they don't really like
to mix with the Americans.
Wow.
With the Anglos.
It's fascinating.
Really.
That Guy Philip k,
Dick,
you know,
am I saying his name right?
He really is.
He's really a,
he's really super cool.
Like in terms of the Scifi stuff and um,
you know,
what else has he written?
I've,
I've seen there was another movie that I
saw his,
like within the last two years.
Could you,
could you bring up his,
uh,
his books because I would know what
other movies that you do or did they,
do they adapt of his movies?
What do we got here?
So this guy wrote that show scanner
darkly.
Wow.
That's right.
Damn.
He wrote a lot of shit.
The adjustment team.
Isn't that a movie,
Tim?
That's bureau.
Yeah.
Okay.
Interesting.
Yeah,
the art direction is really cool.
The idea of not so fine America.
You know what's interesting too is you
can still do that in a movie where you
can still play Nazis as long as they're,
you know,
the bad people and some historical thing
or some something that's going on now.
That's really the only way you could
portray Nazis.
Like you're not allowed to be a Nazi for
Halloween.
Sorry.
Right.
Like people have said like people have
tried it and you get called out for it.
Like there's rules now.
You can't be
get on that show.
What are your.
What did your kids go for Halloween?
Did they,
do they do that or do they even.
It was very adorable.
They were Mermaids,
but when you're,
if you're dressing up for Halloween,
you could be so many terrible things.
He could be vampires and werewolves and
demons and everybody's.
Okay,
cool.
Cool.
I went to a plastic straw.
Kingus Khan.
You can be kingus Khan.
Can't be Hitler.
It could be Saddam Hussein and people
will laugh if yes,
sit down was saying we got them,
we got that guy.
But if you dress Mengele,
you've ruined the party.
You dress as Osama bin Laden.
That might get your ass kicked,
you might get your ass kicked for that
one or that was too soon,
but if you dress like you could probably
dress like a.
The president of Iran.
What's that dude's name?
That dude came over here and set a bunch
of crazy shit.
Gay People Boucher,
Boucher,
blah,
blah.
No,
I'm talking about.
Let's just talk about it for a second.
I remember when people were offended
that there was an Anne Frank Halloween
costume.
Now if the point of talking about the
Holocaust or something like that is
never forget and a 14 year old in a non
mocking way wants to embody and frank,
why is that offensive?
I don't understand that,
but they're never going to do it.
Non Mocking.
Right?
Every time you're making a halloween
costume,
you're almost always trying to be silly.
Right?
Frank?
He's hiding in the attic.
Halloween Halloweena cost,
but I don't know.
It all depends on,
to me,
your intentions.
One hundred percent.
You should be able to wear whatever the
fuck you want.
I never understood when that Prince
Harry got all this shit for dressing
like a Nazi.
It was like,
I don't know,
maybe wait,
did he dress,
like announcing he was dressed for,
it was a costume party to veterans.
So like what,
what would you do?
Why would you do that?
You know,
because it doesn't mean he's glorifying
it,
does it?
I guess if he's the prince,
right.
But you could be a Mongol,
you can be one of the Mongol hoards tour
through Europe,
but he's also a symbol unto itself.
He's assemble the English royalty and
all that kind of,
I guess because it's hundreds of
thousands of years later.
But he grew up all right.
He got out of it that motherfuckers
living under a microscope though when he
can get away with,
but pretty much no one can get away with
being a Nazi anymore.
There was a guy from North Carolina or
something like that recently.
Him and his son were Nazis for,
for Halloween.
One person that could get away with it
and I can't say too much because we
haven't released it yet.
But uh,
Gilbert godfried so he can get.
I know it.
If you're a Jew you can get away with
it.
Yeah.
You can,
yeah.
Everybody's,
everybody's,
you know,
everyone seems to.
Yes.
Go ahead and put your right.
I mean remember when she did that?
She dresses a Nazi.
Yeah.
I always think that stuff's funny.
When I was a 13 year old kid and he was
school or grade school,
learning about the first amendment,
this,
one of the reasons I became a comedian
was because I used to just draw
swastikas on my notebooks just because,
just because I knew I was like,
they would teach us about dictatorships,
so I would go,
wow.
So in any other country they can't do
this and I would just do it,
make myself smile and then cross it out
and I go in any other country,
I'd get my tongue cut out.
I go,
that's the beautiful thing is that you
can say fucked up terrible.
You can dress like an asshole.
Like bad taste is not a crime.
Right?
Yeah.
And that was what one of the,
you remember the Yale uprising a couple
of years back,
there was a guy,
I'm Nicholas Greek name and his wife,
they were at Yale and the wife sent out
an email saying that we need to stop
policing people's costumes.
It's Halloween costume.
She got fired and you can have a
politically incorrect ca halloween
costume like we should relax.
And people started freaking out.
They cornered him in the square or
screaming and nick,
here it is,
Chris Christakis,
Christakis,
I don't wanna fuck up.
So Nicholas Christakis.
So uh,
he's a Greek American sociologist and a
physician and he was teaching at Yale
and these kids were,
they confronted them and they were
screaming at him like,
this is our safe place.
You fucking ruined our play.
It was so bizarre and strange and
hostile.
And he was just trapped out there with
these nonsensical kids screaming at him
that he's racist and this whole thing is
racist and he shouldn't be able to wear
whatever costume you want.
Like no one even specified like what
we're talking about.
It was,
it was ethnic costumes that they,
that's supposed to appropriate another
culture.
Even even though like,
you know,
it's just for the party.
I got Adam and people are just looking
for a reason to be upset.
It doesn't have to make any sense.
But,
but the whole idea of like this thing,
this woke a thing like my niece and my
niece and nephew are going to call,
you know they're going to get ready to
go to college and I'm like Oh God,
this is going to be so difficult,
you know,
because they're going to come out of
this machine,
you know,
pretty much looking at me as like,
pretty much I'm already not that
relevant but like just like all of my
references and stuff like that and just
going to be so you know,
inappropriate.
And it's like when you go to college
it's supposed to go to the open your
mind not to really focus your opinion
that you already have.
So that's what I felt was like,
I felt like everybody's like,
I don't want to play college show and
we're all dreading the day when we have
to play a show like that where,
you know,
everybody there has that group think,
you have to adapt and you do a dot.
I know,
you know,
I'm hoping to tap tap fine,
but I'm just saying like playing a
college and now you probably could do
it,
but I don't think I could.
Of course she could.
Uh,
yeah.
You adapt in terms of doing a set.
You can,
you hate yourself,
that ride home,
you won't want to do that.
What you'd want to just be able to do
whatever you want to do and it would
make you want to do it.
So,
so you're not gonna go push it.
Not Offensive or mean.
Yeah.
You're not a bad person.
So they don't take that into account.
It's the words coming out of your mouth.
They taking them literally.
That's why we're in this state,
that we're in that.
Exactly.
That's what I'm saying.
I'll see the irony or the sarcasm in
that.
The sense of humor in this country has
never been lower and I can say that as
like what Jeff's talking about,
like when we were little kids like
blazing saddles and a young
Frankenstein,
these movies that everybody was watching
them enjoying them and stuff like that.
Now they have all these hidden and
people look
into that and I'm like,
you know,
it was just a fun time.
It was just like a fun experience.
It was.
It wasn't like that was like the
template for how to live.
You can bounce back,
but I think what's happening now is
there's a certain number of people that
want to be able to change the way other
people talk and what they talk about
because they are ultra sensitive so they
have this giant reaction to things that
may or may not be relevant and it's a
debate whether or not it's relevant.
Some things we've changed,
right?
Like certain words that used to be able
to say easily just a few years ago,
way hard to get away with saying now
because the culture is shifting in a way
that's becoming more sensitive.
So probably that's good as long as they
understand context and intent context
and Mel Brooks,
because he used the n word 50 times in a
movie.
Of course not.
It's a different time.
When my uncle Murray said,
you know,
I brought,
when I brought a Chinese girlfriend home
to my pop jack and he's like,
east is east and West is west and never
the two shall meet.
We didn't kick my grandfather out of the
family.
We just said character mine into
Congress.
Listen,
guy grew up like we're watching.
We're that guy grew up in world war two.
Of course.
I mean that this no one could ever.
There's no way we're going to understand
that.
The difference in the way people saw the
world that had to deal with an actual
world war two,
this soft pampered ass life we're
living.
I don't condone racism,
but I understand why people hold
grudges.
Right?
If you went over to Vietnam and lost
half your fucking friends and you came
back over here and you're fucked up
still because of it.
I don't condone racism,
but I think that anytime you're forced
into a situation where your country is
at war with another side,
it's probably really hard for people to
forgive people.
Right.
You know?
I mean,
how.
How hard is it?
That was one of the things that someone
said about the Japanese and not really
too thrilled with Americans and I said,
well,
how?
How do you think you'd feel if you were
showing up 40 years after someone had
literally nuked your country twice,
just annihilated hundreds of thousands
of people with one bomb.
I mean,
mean,
made shadows on the concrete of where
someone's body used to be.
Just vaporize them.
Women,
children,
babies,
grandma,
grandpa,
everybody gets it.
Boom.
I mean,
who the fuck is going to be nice after
that?
It takes a long time to forget that
shit.
Who is that baseball?
The Japanese baseball guy.
How are you?
Oh yeah.
That got to negotiate that into the
contract and you've got to give me a
little extra for Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
Reparation little things.
They did it twice.
America doesn't give itself enough shit
for having the interment camps here.
I had been on one of those.
There's one up on a Washington state on
Bainbridge island,
right?
There's one on Bainbridge island.
Really?
Bainbridge is beautiful.
I can't believe you to determine camp
there,
doesn't Jesus?
We're not all and we got into that
war late,
man.
We don't give ourselves enough shit for
that either.
Yeah.
Does it once in.
I'm the guy from Star Trek.
Yeah,
isn't,
wasn't he?
It was his name.
George George.
George Guy.
He's a survivor.
He lived in a Japanese internment camp.
It was a little kid and for FDR was
president for four terms.
Isn't it crazy?
What's he really president for four
term?
He died in a year and it was fourth
term.
How can you share about that?
Was it for three?
But it definitely was more than three
and then he got elected and they stopped
after that.
They will like.
It can only be two,
but I bet you that are going to.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
If you had a great president though,
like I want to keep doing this job.
Did that awesome.
CEO of Google,
like kicking ass.
Now you got to step it down,
Bro.
Only eight years,
right?
It's like the only gig where when you're
really.
It has so much power.
Really.
You just can't keep running this.
You got to give up the reins.
Like everybody has to give up the reins.
We'd never let the best person to run it
forever.
You would think once Clinton got ahead
of steam under him,
you know,
just feed is carnal desires and just
quarterback.
You know,
you're only gonna have a few good years.
Seasons.
Right?
But how many years do you think the
public would have kept him in?
Like say if you had a guy like Barack
Obama,
how many years,
if they just let them go until he
doesn't want to do it anymore,
until we don't want them to do it
anymore.
How many years you think you keep doing
it?
Man,
he might be able to do it for four or
five terms maybe more easily.
Especially if it showed that his
policies were working.
Because you know a lot of these
policies,
economic policies,
they take years in order to see real
world benefits.
Look,
if you take the actual campaigning out
of it,
you know,
they're really only president for two
years because it's like they're
campaigning on the way in and then the
campaigning on the way out and it's
like,
you know,
that's for all of our government and
like we're all like I guess victims of
that so sad,
but calender,
trying to explain it the other day about
the amount of time that a congressman or
senator or any politician spends raising
money versus the amount of time that
they spend actually doing their job.
It's like it's not even close
and it's so humbling that their job is
awesome.
We see them on cspan banging a gavel and
making a point and handing out a metal
to a soldier and then you go see an
actual political fundraiser and it's
like boring.
It's like cory booker standing on a
basement floor at canter's on a Sunday
morning and there's no glamor to it at
all.
Now.
They have the worst gig ever.
If I took you to,
if we were,
the three of us had to show up where
politicians have to show up to raise
money.
You'd be screaming at your age and
going,
are you fucking kidding me with this
microphone?
And there's no.
There's no lights and no one could hear
me and I'm fucking talking to a wall.
There's no food.
Wouldn't starve.
That's like the worst.
That is a could see why anybody would do
this fricken job of,
of trying to.
I'm going to try to help people.
Fuck you.
We're going to expose.
You are going to beat you up.
We're going to go at all your busy,
you know.
But trump was the only one that did it
with a built in giant audience right
from the jump.
Like right from the jump.
He had a giant audience going crazy
tours on our dime.
If Hillary right now,
real housewives instead of the Senate,
she would've been president.
She had just feed.
You mentioned seeing Hillary bill around
the house.
Famous for just being a lady sort of
being a politician.
That's true.
She probably would have and in some
ways,
right?
She was almost like hindered by the fact
that she was Bill Clinton's wife.
If she was just a,
a senator by herself with a lawyer who
became a senator,
she probably would have way more of a
shot of winning.
Same Person.
Right?
People always say,
you know,
what did bill,
what did trump do for the working man?
He entertained them.
Like show is great.
People love that show.
It's true.
Don't you click on the stories first?
You don't go to,
you know,
you're not reading about the,
the,
the genocide in Rwanda.
You're,
you're reading the trump,
like accidentally spelled something
wrong.
Right?
From top news story.
That's our.
Yeah.
Lately there's all these new charges
have been brought up that I didn't know
about and new people are getting
arraigned and it's like,
it's a crazy.
It's like watching a crazy separate.
We have very short attention
that man in this country and like we,
we expect results,
you know?
And that's why in the new cycle the way
it is now,
it's like,
you know,
you.
Have you ever been in a hotel where
you'll watch,
like for some reason you're caught in
like the three or four hour news cycle
where you see the same story,
whatever,
and then there's like one more detail
and then they'll start it up again and
you're like,
wow,
you know,
I'm going to get a phone call because
now I could be a panelist.
I know everything,
you know,
like we figured it out.
He was wearing shoes,
but I still watch TV news shows though
online.
Dave knows every show I love.
I love,
I like the um,
I,
I liked watching the whole day cycle,
you know,
like I,
I just think it's,
especially when it's something like an
event that's happening and you get to
see,
you know,
them figuring it out because they can't
wait for,
to know this whole story now because he
has to be immediate.
So you get,
you get to see them,
like started,
you know,
and it's like,
it's really like,
it's like going to journalism school
almost,
you know,
like,
okay,
something bad happened here.
And then like they're working on their
bits.
Yeah,
exactly.
They have to introduce them like right
where breaking news,
breaking news.
We'd been told they don't know exactly
what the fuck's going on.
That's definitely like,
you know,
my mom,
she has some memory issues and stuff
like that,
but like waiting till 6:00
to find out what happened in the world,
you know,
like that's those days over.
Can you imagine if
we did that?
Like that's a new rule,
you know,
those days are over like a guy.
I remember when the.
I'm like,
how did we get through the whole day?
Right.
How did we get to the door?
I remember when the challenger blew up,
what they used to do back in the day,
they would interrupt.
Yes.
And that was exciting.
Big.
We have some terrible news and the world
of entertainment.
We have to pause the game.
Just to Howard.
I was sitting on the bed with my dad
watching Monday night football and
cosell just changes mood.
All of a sudden the music,
Beatles legend John Lennon and I thought
he said John,
Jack Lemon,
you know,
John Lennon was assassinated outside his
apartment.
And that's like,
yeah.
You remember broadcasting Howard cosell
announcing something or when the moon
launch took off.
There's no moment now where you're like,
oh,
I remember a certain members,
certain broadcast are announcing a
certain thing.
No,
no.
You hear one version of it.
Then you hear so many versions of it.
You forget which one you heard first.
Like I remember when I saw that fell
when I saw it the first time I saw it on
television.
I didn't know.
I don't know who said it.
I don't know who was giving the news
cast.
It didn't,
doesn't even register.
Just have to.
You just have to be believable.
That was.
Yeah,
that was definitely a local news moment
because I was in New York and my mom
goes,
turn on the TV and then we could see the
coverage right there.
So was like,
that was before the web where you could
go like,
okay,
I'm going to get deeper into this.
It was like waiting on the next bit of
information.
So I was,
I was laying in bed in New York and I
found out from the great newscaster,
Ralphie May,
who was
screaming into my Edward,
he knew I was flying out of New York
that day and he had,
he had,
he was in la and he's trying to,
he's like Toronto and it was just him
yelling to my answering machine.
It was like entered my dream and I kinda
heard sirens in the back of my dream
cars.
They'll look ambulances running down
Broadway and I turned it on just to see
the second tower fall down.
And Ralphie,
he was my Walter Cronkite,
Ralphie,
ms dot that guy.
We lost a lot of good ones this year.
Sean rouse?
Yes.
Do you know Joe is a great opener of
mine.
He was so funny,
man.
Great Guy.
I only saw them in weird places with
Dave.
Like guys,
we're pals.
Yeah,
he was really good.
And um,
you know,
right out of Texas and uh,
he was such a good guy.
He was out of the Houston area,
Houston.
He was such a good,
a lot of that old laptop in river oaks.
There was a lot of great comics.
Those local guys,
they had quality local comics like you
would,
you would do a set there and the guys
would open for you.
You'd be like,
Holy Shit,
you guys are funny.
And do you remember like the whole myth
of the Texas outlaws?
Like I used to eat that up.
I was like,
tell me another story.
I want to hear another story that was
Hixon Kennison
really low.
And,
and,
uh,
Jimmy Pineapple,
the pineapple.
I worked with Jimmy Pineapple first time
I ever did that club there.
Great Guy.
Funny Dude too.
Yeah,
those guys like Jefferson,
Jimmy,
Joe.
I never thought it could be pineapple.
I don't think I even heard of him until
funny dude.
He was one of the outlaws.
Early outlaws will shoot Schubert.
Schubert used to go on the road with
them too.
You know,
Marin Marin was one of the guys that was
with them in town.
I didn't know that.
I to become one of the Texas comedy
outlaw.
How deep it was.
Like a group of these wild comics down
in area.
There was Jimmy Pineapple looking guy.
Gloria,
small springish on microphone.
Funny Dude though.
I don't want to put in new stuff out
there.
Get a good guy though too.
I've worked with them.
Was Really Nice.
James sign up.
That was when I first worked at club.
I love that club.
That was one of the greatest rooms of
all time,
man.
I did my,
uh,
warner brothers cd there in 1999.
Wow.
Yeah.
That fucking club was so hot.
It was packed.
Tight ceiling.
Wild motherfuckers,
Texas people.
Wild Texas Pete.
Just chaos.
Drinking good times.
Fun.
Nice.
People that are smart,
but they're also like to get fucked up.
Absolutely.
You in Texas this weekend?
I don't know where I am yet.
You don't know where you.
I'm waiting to hear on my schedule
because you have a phone.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's buffering.
But I actually took dave to a phone
store.
Yeah.
You know,
we were preparing for the tapings and he
never texted me back and I'm like,
we're walking by this and I'm like,
just come in and look.
And he literally looks at the iphone
like it's the enemy of the people.
It's the stain.
You have an iphone also.
I got the guy goes,
you could do anything on this.
You could text,
you can make a point,
you could do anything,
you can record your shows.
And Dave goes,
should we really play?
God?
I had a couple of good lines,
but uh,
I don't go past an iphone too.
I feel like,
you know,
that's pushing it because now it's like
up to 10,
right?
You have an iphone too,
like,
yeah.
How many are,
how many articles compared to Jv burst?
How many iphones compared to how many
rocky movies are there?
Rocky movies are there now.
[inaudible] name is Hobie rockies
because now we have d dos creeds.
The second thing act now,
like I say it is because it's working
off of the actual narrative of rocky.
Do you hear Michael b?
Jordan is talking about boxing.
Roy Jones Jr.
Yeah.
I thought that was a cool kind of hope.
It's a joke.
Just straight up boxing and not like a
meu moitai.
Listen,
don't do that michael.
Just don't do that.
I'm sure he's a great athlete.
He's a beautiful kid.
Has got a great bodY.
It looks like he knows how to box when
he throws punches.
It looks like you really actually knows
how to box.
I'm sure he's a really good athlete and
it's built like a brick shithouse,
but boxing.
Roy jones jr is a pastor.
Someone that had to get hit upside.
You'll never work again or you'll become
a box.
Yeah.
You hang in there with them and you
look like your hero.
Me.
You clip them and hurt him.
I mean it is.
It is a humanly possible thing,
right?
Like when two people throwing punches at
each other that one of them could hit
the other guy,
but the downside is ruined.
Boy jones is one of the greatest boxers
of all time and still to this day knows
how to box.
it's not like he forgot he's pushing 50,
49.
Yeah,
he's pushing 50.
If you think somebody,
someone who's like deal with it.
I think it was just talking shit.
He was just probably being asked like
who would you like to box?
Who is your hero and how many rounds to
go certain amount.
What exactly happened?
He said he would.
He asked them,
who would you want to fight today?
And he said,
Roy Jones,
he would probably beat me in his prime,
but I'd probably find them today.
It's probably just like that is an
outrageous thing to say.
Just an asshole thing to say.
George foreman.
Listen,
he probably would kill you in his prime
when the idea that he would just beat
you mean Roy Jones jr.
When he was in his prime,
you would Just waiting to see.
He was a nas song.
they said Roy Jones is in the new mike
tyson's Roy Jones.
It's in.
This is like in the 19 nineties.
People forgot how good Roy Jones jr was.
He was putting his hands behind his back
and then knocking people out.
He was doing ridiculous shit.
Knocked out light heavyweight champion.
Virgil hit with a body shot to hear it
so we can hear the context.
Okay,
sure.
Let's listen to it.
I heard that you,
after all your training for the creed,
you can hold your own in a fight thing a
little bit.
You know what?
I've been working out with rocky,
but we're going out with like,
you know,
saying like apollo creed.
I'M going to go up.
Absolutely.
So now who all time would you want to
step into the rooM with?
But there's a boxer,
a wrestler by Roy Jones,
bro.
That's my dude.
I can do my thing a little bit.
Yeah,
that whoLe monthly.
Right now it's prime now.
Hip hop.
It knocked my esl,
but like right now I can do one thing.
Why answer that question?
He was a show where you funnier than
george carlin and his prime.
Can you just answer that right now?
Since he did?
I know you've had a few drinks and the
restaurant and take some right now.
I'm on coke.
Coke.
Let me answer some questions.
Roy jones jr said he was trading with
rocky.
That was the best part.
And apollo creed,
you know their names and he doesn't know
that old dude.
The old dude,
the black guy,
the black guy.
Black panther too.
He's awesoMe.
Plays a good superhero.
He's a great guy.
I love his movies.
He was a good bad guy in that movie.
But you know,
it's like,
just shouldn't answer that just made a
mistake,
you know,
young,
cocky,
full life.
Look,
everything's going well now.
and again,
built like a goddamn superhero.
Probably thinks he could box the world.
There's Just a different thing that's
going to be happening if you're standing
in front of Roy Jones jr,
it's a different thing.
He's,
yeah,
he's got a computer that's many,
many times more robust
than yours when it comes to box,
it's just taking the punishment.
It's not like,
you know,
it's like,
okay,
that's enough.
It gives you a concussion and you never
act again.
What's the upside for?
You can tee up on the way a 50 year old
boxer.
It looks at this actor,
pretty boy.
And it's like,
uh,
when they bought that,
when they broke,
um,
what's his name?
Out of the box and pulp fiction.
Yeah.
I mean he's jack though.
Look at them to them seriously.
But see,
the thing is like,
there's such a giant difference between
learning how to box and being a good
athlete.
He clearly is.
And being Roy Jones jr,
the,
the gap is so wide.
It's so,
it's like if I did a movie about playing
basketball and then I wanted to,
you know,
play a one on one versus coby.
Brian,
you'll have been planning this movie for
a couple of.
I'm feeling good even though I never did
any competitive basketball player.
You were in the white shadow.
It's like He got beat up.
It's like he's,
he's a movie star brown.
He's got fake blood on his whelks that
was in the movie.
I'm sure he knows how to throw his
hands.
I'm sure he does.
He looks good in the movies.
He looks like he really knows what he's
doing.
but Roy Jones jr is one of the greatest
of all time.
He was a female.
He knows how to box in a way that you
never going to understand.
So how long has he been simply boxed?
Ten years.
I mean Roy Jones had a fight within the
last two years.
I think his last fight was,
I wanna say it was two less than two
years ago.
I think he retired.
He had a bunch of fights over in Russia.
He actually became a russian citizen.
Is that it?
This year?
Jesus christ place some of it.
Play.
He's a retired boxer.
Challenging a box.
Fucking Roy Jones jr.
All right.
Just this is a different thing.
It's one thing if you're like a top
level pro right now and you feel like
you would have got knocked out by ryan
is probably,
but you can give them a goal right now.
Okay.
that I.
That is.
That's believable.
You're a professional boxer.
You've been honing your craft in the gym
for years and years.
You've been sparring and work with high
level coaches.
Look at him.
He's still Roy Jones jr.
Still Roy Jones jr.
Even though he's 40,
it doesn't matter if he's boxing one's a
boxer,
but Roy Jones is in a boxing match here
and he's looking good.
I mean,
he's obviously not fighting a guy who's
the best.
Roy jones jr.
Do you call your your agent right now?
Serious.
What's the money?
He's already been doing all these
interviews.
Just said,
look,
I don't want to get out of bed early in
the morning,
but if you know,
if he wants to really do this,
we could do this.
I think it'd be a wonderful opportunity
to show people what boxing is.
Oh,
let me see what he said.
I would love to see that here.
Let's see what roy says.
Of course I saw the video.
Birthing is a duct to fight in my life.
NothIng right now.
Hurricane to come down here so ain't
nobody real content
and we will make happen.
You got my number.
He can cut you and get my number.
So there's no question about high.
No.
From tmc.
The list may happen
right now.
He said in the video,
he said,
I think he would probably have killed me
back in his prime.
That's true though.
Do you actually many kids beat you now
even though you are 49 boy.
No,
you can't beat me still because I mean I
know he's probably a better condition
because he's younger.
He probably think he can go longer and
probably thinks he might be able to even
at working now,
but I'm a bit old.
School ain't going out like that to me.
I love you.
Understand me.
So opened unstable box.
We'll just take them out right away
because then you don't get the
experience with box.
I'm a professional like I am,
and I know you big and strong because
you've got strong for the movie.
Then I should be able to avoid all of
that.
Take them into deep water so you
understand what a boxing match release
comes out.
He don't want to say,
oh,
I've got.
No,
no,
no.
I'm a nice five,
six rounds.
So I want you to see how it really
feels.
So that's why I'm talking like that now
because I think he can really match my
skills.
I really don't even that for tonight.
How long would you need to get right to
where you could step in there?
Like,
what's the soonest we could make this
fight happen?
Uh,
probably for him about four or five
weeks.
Michael,
please listen to me.
Don't do this.
Someone called stubhub.
Just don't do this,
do this.
This is not gonna work out well,
especially if they're,
I would assume both of them are not
going to be drug tested.
I don't think either one of them wants
to pee in a bucket.
If they just let roy,
they let roy go to dr feelgood,
pump them up with hormones.
This is going to be a route.
This would be terrifying.
I imagine getting a call from his agent,
hey,
we have an offer for you to do this,
like new superhero movie.
It's gonna be amazing,
and michael is like,
ah,
I'm booked that whole five weeks,
five weeks.
I got to train for Roy Jones jr,
like,
don't do it,
but this is a new genre of tv show of
the real guy versus the guy playing.
Want to see doctors against guys who
played a dr alessi astronauts against
guys who was picked or an astronaut.
I want to see it all.
Navy seals,
navy dinosaur versus chicken.
I want to say it.
Isn't that what mark walberg side,
if he was on the plane with five versus
city,
did he really say that though?
That's what everybody says.
I never heard him say the things.
Think a crazy thing.
Thank you.
Know who knows what the fuck you would
do if you thought that you were just
going to land somewhere.
Now that's the idea is that you knew
what was gonna happen before it
happened.
Nobody knows about.
Well,
that shit's going down.
Someone's got box cutters.
They were holding the waitress.
They're holding a stewardess by the
neck,
like you know,
you don't know what fuck's happening.
You have no idea what's going on.
You're afraid to move and you know,
I'm sure that a lot of people would step
up,
but you know,
it could potentially cost that person in
their life and then when the plane
lands,
that person's dead when they may be.
If you don't know,
right?
You don't know the actual scenario.
Now obviously we know was a horrible
thing and you should do whatever you can
to stop them because they're going to
kill everybody no matter what.
But back then you didn't know what I
mean.
If someone just took the plane and
landed in the stewardess,
he would be like,
glad I didn't do anything.
She jumped up and he cut her face off.
You know,
it's like in those moments when you
don't know what's going to happen to.
I was on that plane.
Okay.
With my kids,
the window went down like it did.
That would have been a lot of blood in
that first class cabin.
Then me saying,
okay,
we're going to land somewhere safely.
Don't worry.
Know that.
See I,
I see where he's coming from.
Right?
He's got a.
He's got kids that he loves.
He's got a family that he loves.
He wouldn't have said still.
That's what he's saying.
Yeah.
That's what you're saying.
And then in his mind he probably has
that conviction.
Even if it meant the thing that winning
everybody's life,
would you know,
would it work if it didn't work?
Like what do they have?
Do you know what they have?
You know,
they don't know.
You don't have a box cutter.
They have anything else?
How many of them are there?
You don't know.
Is anybody going to back you up?
Does anybody else know how to fight?
You know,
you could get fucked up.
You could.
You could step up thinking you'Re billy
bad ass and this guy is some train the
trainers who smashes your face in and
cuts you up with a box cutter that could
happen to.
It still pulls his belt off the planet.
You could.
Who the fuck knows matt the.
That's why there's professionals,
right?
That's where there's professional.
Those air marshals can assess the
situation and figure out and obviously,
you know,
they weren't either they weren't there
on that plane or they couldn't help.
I was thinking about if I was in that
position,
I'd,
you know,
how could you.
I mean,
who the fuck knows what you would do?
Well,
since I look like I'm on the other team,
I would've said my friends.
Fuck,
come on,
get up and do your.
I'm like,
I'm not part of the team.
Do your foreign guy.
Fuck man.
Yeah.
You'd be,
you know,
I've never been so scared that you're
frozen instance for a second.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I mean you,
you can't know what the right thing to
do is in the wrong thing.
Could be so catastrophic.
Right.
As far as to say that he's making
announcements on the plane and this is
all happening like brittle landing safe,
like he's now the pilot in the movies,
right?
That's true movie.
You get to grant the intercom at the end
and go,
thanks for flying solo and solera.
Sometimes you say things like that
because that's how you feel and you
don't think about how other people are
going to perceive it.
That's what I would assume that
statement is.
It's kind of how he felt like,
fuck that.
I'm landing this fucking plane.
I'm killing the fucking terrorists.
Yeah,
that's what he told his kids one night.
The problem is you're saying that to
billions of people and billions of
people hear that and they go,
what?
And then all these people get to assess
your.
Your statement whether or not it has any
makes any sense.
Like what are you going to do?
You can kick everybody's ass.
Okay,
sure.
I know a lot of dudes who,
if they were there and you try to do
that,
you'd get smashed.
Like they're scary people in this world
than weapons on him.
I would assume.
If you're ready to die like that,
you have a very strange kind of
conviction to if you know you're ready
to die and you know how to fight like
woo Jesus.
I don't mean who knows,
but it's
Just
the idea that you would have to think
about it.
That's what's really terrifying.
What do you mean?
The idea that you would have to think
like,
what do I do if something is someone
does.
Hi,
don't we all think that?
Yeah.
Every,
every situation now there's what we do
do.
Do.
Do you hear people run and they survive
and people run and get shot down and
they go to the wrong way.
Anytime a tragedy like that happen,
like what the fuck?
Horrific random Set of sequences and
you're in the wrong spot.
You can do the right.
Heroic.
How about how many people must do the
heroic thing and then you die anyway.
You never know about it.
Oh,
for sure.
I wonder what uncle steve did in that
situation.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's a lot of.
It seems like those fucking things are
happening more and more lately.
It is.
Is the rate more accelerated now than
it's ever been before,
as well as the numbers of these
shootings and shit.
Sorry,
what is happening?
Like what the fuck is going on that this
keeps happening?
If they happened like every couple of
days there's like a little one,
like a two or three people.
One,
she's like not that big a deal anymore.
Well that's what it was when it was
about knives and swords.
People would go on a killing spree,
but now it's,
You kill more people and you know,
not everybody would die with a knife.
London.
And as a bunch of knife attacks,
london has so many knife attacks that
their uh,
their,
their murder rate exceeded New York
city's murder rate with just knives.
Wow.
Oh,
google that.
Make sure that true.
The machete attack,
the fucking president or the mayor of
president,
the mayor of london saying something
that they won't tolerate knives anymore.
Can't have knives.
Sounds sounds better.
I know,
but everybody's like that
in New York know knives.
You have a guy who's a off his meds and
he's just like walking around with a
hammer.
you know.
So it could happen,
it doesn't really matter what the weapon
is.
Okay.
London has overtaken New York for
murders for the first time in modern
history,
after a surge of knife crime's across
the capital verdict,
though selective of statistics
from the start of 2018 appeared to bear
this out.
But the reality is that New York still
appears to be more violent than london.
Yes,
that was written.
It was written by a new yorker,
New York,
and back.
Right now,
man,
New York is on fire.
It's great.
We love it.
I haven't been there as much in the last
few weeks,
but when I'm there and all summer I was
there.
It's,
you're a freedom guy.
I love the way you're living your life.
You just fly here,
fly there.
Have you been to his houses or have you
been to?
I've seen photos of the pool.
The la one is awesome.
The New York one is like,
um,
I dunno,
dump he.
You could tell like he doesn't live
there,
you know,
it's like a crash pad,
but it's a,
it's a,
it's a nice place.
I'm not saying it isn't,
but it's an old school,
New York building with the elevator with
the guy has to use the elevator operator
gold.
Fancy snobby fifth avenue.
Co up Mr.
Ross.
Snobby.
But like,
you know,
I had to go through a co op interview.
Buddy hackett wrote my recommendation.
That's hilarious.
York.
It's all rules.
So many permits.
Um,
you know,
out god is tricky.
There's shootings,
there's fires.
That's why the caravan turn back.
Does that one,
do you see the photos of people like
running towards the border and gas
coming out?
Him and the whole idea of like knowing
that there's a big group of people
headed towards the border.
I'm like,
what is this?
Like,
what's going on here?
What?
What's people are flinging?
They're terrified.
Imagine what they are leaving to come to
that.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
No,
I imagine what's at home,
but it's always playing that it's all
this planned out event.
Like everybody's watching the migration
board.
The board this ever happened before.
Yeah.
There was something that someone posted
about obama in 2013.
The deal during the obama administration
wasn't like obama was fucking tear gas
over the fence,
but somebody during that administration
appeared to have used a tear tear gas on
an illegal immigrant as well,
but it wasn't.
I don't think it was this kind of thing.
This kind of thing seems
like the cuban boatlift,
like that's what I felt like about it as
like they're fleeing,
you know,
like a dead spot or you know.
Yeah.
It's political and economic.
It's everything mean we,
they want to come to the promise land
like all of our ancestors did.
That's why we're here.
But then we got to a point where
I don't think it's just about just about
they want to come here,
it's about what's at home.
That they got to get away from this.
Yes.
And now with the internet and
information,
they go,
wow,
maybe we don't have to be in this gang.
Sure.
Maybe I can get my kid out when he's
three instead of watching them die at
15.
Yeah.
And have opportunity.
I mean,
that's what everybody wanted.
The came here in the first place.
It's just at this point,
if you're a poor person from Guatemala,
I mean,
how is it to immigrate to America if you
don't have any skills,
you have a very short education.
It's got to be really fucking hard to
become a us citizen.
Probably super difficult.
You got to be super brave.
I would go to learn another language to
really figure out how to get through all
the other countries and the new America.
You don't have to learn it,
but it certainly helps.
If you want to thrive.
I would go to Costa Rica.
Have you been down there?
Love it.
Yeah,
like everybody I know who's been there,
they're like,
this is the place.
Like I'm going to move here after I
retire,
so that might be like a good second
place.
Guy offered me.
We'd girls and coke in front of my
daughter while I was holding her hand.
I was like,
damn.
And surf lessons.
It's like everybody.
There was a professional surfer on the
beach,
man,
girls,
you want coke?
You want.
I'm like,
yo bro.
Holding up five-year-old's hand is
outraged.
She's like discount.
I'm like,
what dude is offer me cocaine like right
there.
What you need to.
Monkeys are everywhere,
man.
Everywhere you go,
monkeys.
Fucking date.
They eat oreos.
They open them up and chew the white
part first.
Yeah.
They eat so many that they know how to
pop them up and they chew that white
shit show.
Yeah.
We were concerned.
We were like,
should we really give the monkey a
cookie and cookies are toxic.
It's all sugar.
We gave them monkeY.
The monkey took that thing.
Pop the tYpe stuff probably lives on a
steady diet of oreos.
Oreos are the minibar.
That hotel and the monkeys right there
give have a oreo man.
I don't want to see them.
They have no fear of.
People just have a little bit of fear.
There's a little bit of apprehension.
There's a there.
They'd be definitely size you up because
I'm sure they run into dickhead humans
and they're fucking dangerous man.
I mean if they decide to fuck you up,
they can hurt you.
They can call your face apart,
can.
They can really do damage if there,
especially this side of the act as a
group,
but they just seem to be a monkey
swinging at me once on a tv set and I'll
never.
I'll never go to another one.
Suite your face.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I was holding his hand.
We were entering it like we were
entering.
I was hosting a gong show pilot a
million years ago and I was entering
with a fucking gym pole in his hand.
We were in champ matching tuxedos and I
got along with them all day rehearsals
and then whatever.
When that band kicked in and the lights
were in the role and the audience he
cherished,
he really.
I don't know if he was asking for more
money or.
Oh,
that makes sense,
man.
It probably hurt his ears.
Probably so confused.
All the people there doesn't speak your
language.
Doesn't know what the fuck you're
saying.
Right,
right.
Wow.
I have a good monkey story.
Nobody has any good one.
I do like where I was on another tv show
and the.
They had the Monkey and they go,
hey,
like whatever,
clara,
belle,
whatever your name is there like this is
dave,
shake hands and the monkey a didn't even
stop hugging the person,
just let
the foot come up and I shook their foot
because their feet are like hands and I
was like,
how cool is that?
I couldn't get over it.
I was like,
if You could shake hands with your feet,
like when did you do it?
All the time.
It's like,
oh hey,
what's up?
Okay.
So I can keep doing my other stuff.
Yeah.
Like,
yeah.
I was like,
that's really cool.
I just shook.
Feed him versatile.
Yeah.
All right.
Maybe it's not that great a story,
but I still think that's a good monkey
story.
That's a win for both.
I like communication,
but then you know parrots,
of course we can talk about it all
night.
People who keep parents his pads and
then they die because parents lived to
be 90 days.
She gets some old lady's parents still
got 60 years left in it.
Yeah.
And they're racIst.
Who wants them?
Full fucking tank.
That parents get a full tank to take
that thing.
take your pills,
take your pills.
You always want attentIon.
they're weird.
Yeah,
they want to sit right on your shoulder
or hidden in your hand.
They want you to open up the cage.
Talk to them.
They want to be around you all the time.
Parents are smart,
man.
They do not like to get just left alone.
If you think you're going to be some
asshole as acute bird sitting in the
cage,
the middle of your living room.
Oh,
that's my parent.
I'm interesting.
No,
that parent needs you.
Hey.
They want attention,
like come on mother fucker.
I don't want to just sit in this case.
Let me out.
Let's walk around.
Let me sending your shoulder,
but I don't know.
See what's on tv.
Come on.
Fucking board.
Parents are smart,
man.
The reason why they are not smart,
they live that long.
They live all long time.
A long time.
I think smarter or dumber than out
davis theory.
I'm always in search of the next
algebra.
That's my big thing.
Well,
we know that ravens are really smart.
There's a super smart,
they solve puzzles and shit,
like scientists set up all these
puzzles.
Ravens with they'll,
yeah,
they'll take a stick and then use the
stick to get a longer stick and then use
that stick to get the,
get the food out,
like multistep,
like problem solving.
Ravens can do weird shit.
But uh,
and we know that a bunch,
a bunch of other different birds are
pretty fucking smart,
but I don't know,
my hawks,
my hawks hawks in my neighborhood,
they're smart who fly right over my
house all the time and they're
fascinating to watch.
They really like to show off.
Yeah.
I would assume that all those predators
have to be smart.
I mean they just,
they have to be ruthless and smart,
you know,
to get along if you're out there picking
up squirrels and rats and shit,
like they are doing digital firebomb and
out of the sky snatching things up from
angles that only they understand.
My friend tom was in his backyard
sitting down having a cup of coughing
and he saw dove landed on top of his
fence and then out of nowhere this hawk
just chucked at da boom.
He said it was like a big explosion of
feathers that the hawk just swooped in
going like 150 miles an hour glass,
snatch the dove right off it and it took
off and he was just sitting there with
his coffee and his like,
what the fuck?
Wow.
Goes Like 10 yards from my head.
It just thought it was dove.
I would have kicked.
Fucking landed safely.
Would've landed safely back on your
buddy friend told everybody if I was a
dove,
would kids kids have to do with the
plane?
Well that would make them motivated.
He's a,
he's a,
you know,
I'm protected.
I see.
Yeah.
Don't give him that.
He probably does have to fight a little
bit too.
It looks like he does.
He does.
In the movie play.
Micky ward.
Looks like he knows how to box.
He definitely knows how to throw
punches,
you know.
This is michael b.
Jordan.
Thanks fascinating to me because he'll
listen.
He made money on it.
I hope it does.
Someone will tell them I'm looking.
I'm sure he's a smart guy and I'm sure
he's a great athlete and I'm sure he
probably knows how to box a little bit,
but if you kind of box guy like roy,
jonah,
you know what you do,
you started the amateurs and you learn
how to box and then you become a
professional and then one day you box
Roy Jones newman and the race cars.
So yeah,
you're not going,
you're not getting hit.
See,
the very unique thing about combat
sports is you're getting hit,
so it's not like someone's dunking on
you.
Like if you played basketball with coby
bryant,
you're going to get lit up,
you're going to look like a fool,
but you're not going to get hit a few
boxes.
Roy jones jr.
You're gonna get you're gonna get
dinged.
Michael Jordan got knocked out during
decreed,
filming acts by with an accidental punch
that landed where they.
Yeah,
where they were hitting him and he tried
to like turn his head at the last
minute,
but they didn't turn it quick enough and
he got clipped and dropped.
Maybe that's why he knows he can take a
punch now.
Well,
I mean maybe that's given him the
confidence.
He did it on purpose.
He was.
I think it just.
I think,
you know,
the way it was like you take the punch
then turn your habit.
It looked like he took the punch just a
little too hard.
That's real,
right?
That looks good,
but it isn't really real gloves there.
Then I use them regularly.
They're using boxing gloves.
Could it be bullshit?
I love those korean movies and they see
something like this.
You don't know if it's like some thing
they do for a publicity stunt.
Like,
watch this,
see that they're practicing like this.
See right there.
Now see that's real dude.
Yeah,
that's real.
See the way his head snaps in his eyes.
Go play that again.
That's real.
I know what a real knockout looks like.
I've seen a thousand of them in person.
That's a real knockout.
Watch.
This look at this,
he fucked up and he's out cold dude.
He's out cold.
One hundred percent.
Watch this.
He ran right into the punch.
His head snapped Back,
his eyes rolled behind his head and he
wants conscious yet,
but that is 100 percent legit knockout.
But that punch was not even a punch.
What,
what,
what he was hit with.
He even had a mystery behind it.
He didn't have any power behind it.
So he was basically knocked out Just by
coincidence.
No,
no.
There's definitely power behind it.
If they say yes,
yes,
yes.
Listen,
you could kao someone easily just doing
that easily.
That was perfect punch.
It was a perfect punch that landed on
his jaw as he was moving forward.
That's the key.
The key is that he was turning his head
into it and he didn't think it was
coming in and he took it right on the
jaw if you want play it because I didn't
see.
What he's doing is he's there.
They're choreographing how the sequence
is going to go and somewhere along the
line,
either as a miscalculation or a mistake
was made.
So this will be Jordan,
what's this?
What's this?
Right here?
See that he fucked up and they turned in
to do it and that guy is throwing like.
I mean,
even though it's not the most powerful
punch in the world,
it's faster than I thought and he knows
how to punch.
Okay.
So his weight is behind that.
His shoulders behind that.
That's a guy who's punched people in the
face before he knows exactly how to do
it.
So even though he's only doing it like
this,
even though he's only doing that.
So you'll run into it and he catches it
on the chin.
You're going out of course.
and that's what happened.
So why,
why did that get a leak?
She didn't know if it got leaked or if
they put it out on perfect,
they put it out to show that they
probably probably put it out to show you
this is hard training they're doing for
this.
And you know,
there was an accident on the set and he
got knocked out.
I will be not the clip I'd want out
there if I was him,
but it turns into a site that was.
He was younger than.
He's bigger and stronger now.
He's older.
His body's more mature,
but either way.
Oh,
I want a box.
Roy jones.
The first one you got to become a career
boxer.
I mean,
unless he's like so old,
you can't take a punch.
It's not going to do it.
Or he would never have given up his
strategy like that.
I need them five,
six rounds.
That's just shit talking.
Anything did that his whole career.
Exactly how he was going to beat guys
this whole career choice.
Really.
He's still Roy Jones jr.
This is crazy.
Talk like him saying just played dumb
and be like,
he's good.
I'll do it.
That's not what he would do.
He would say,
this is how I'm going to do it,
and then he would go out and do it.
Say,
I'm going to need you to get tired out.
See what it feels like to be in a real
fight.
It take a beating.
Yeah,
man,
look,
if I can tell was junior just gets you
into the third,
fourth and fifth round and you're all,
your adrenaline dump.
Dump is gone because you're not used to
boxing a worldclass boxer in a
professional matches on paper view that
millions of people are watching not used
to that experience.
So that experIence is taxing.
It's nerve racking.
You're going to have all this adrenaline
rush through your body.
Even if you're the the chillest of chill
dude,
you're going to be just a little bit too
amped up,
right?
So then around that second round comes,
then he started,
he even and you can't breathe that good
and you just kinda like,
we're always just kind of boxing.
You just boxing you.
he's not hurting you.
He just boxing you.
Occasionally you get stung a little bit.
Then the third round moves in and he
starts moving left and right and come in
and stinging.
You hard the jab,
stepping in with a lead hand,
upper cut and you're like,
oh fuck yeah.
Now you're getting teed off on and now
he's talking,
he's dancing,
he's moving around and then he's just
charged stolen bombs on you and you
can't defend them because you're
exhausted and he hooks you to the liver
and drops you hunted around trying to
get away from get away.
He's too good.
he's been doing it for too long.
Joan said that.
He says,
yeah,
he probably can go long and hard on me
because he's all trained up,
but do you think he would come and I'm
like full tilt in the first round or two
and just like really like take them to
school.
You know,
like the speed downs.
Dangerous because when you get real
aggressive is when you get hit.
Because when you get real aggressive,
say if I know you're coming at me,
I'm,
you're running at me,
you're running at me.
All I have to do is figure out how much
time and space I need to get something
off as You're coming at me because I
know where you're going.
It's dangerous when you don't know if
someone's coming and going when
someone's not.
When you don't know if they're coming to
going,
that's when a fight is weird.
So the beginning of every fight,
people are feeling each other out.
They don't know if someone's coming to
going.
If I know that you're just running at me
and I'm Roy Jones jr,
I'm going to step back and I'm going to
time it and I crack you and I'm going to
crack you in a way that you probably
don't see coming.
You probably don't see it in the gym too
much.
I'm just going to stiff arm you with a
jab,
pop you in place,
step to the left.
Boom,
he's going to drop out right hand on
your chin.
He's goIng to fuck you up,
and then he's going to turn around.
He's going to be behind you and he's
gonna.
Look at you to see if you're still okay
and then he's going to do it again and
he's going to keep doing it.
If you keep chasing after him,
you're going to still get fucked.
You're going to get fucked up and going
to get your face punched in.
So the only other thing is to do is like
you've got a buxom,
so okay,
now you're boxing one of the greatest
boxers of all time and he just,
and he's just going to just figure you
out.
Like what do you go,
what do you do when I do this?
What happens when I do this?
What happens here?
Could I have punched you?
Oh,
I could have.
And then he's going to figure out when
to move and when you're going to get
tired and he's going to start dropping
bombs on you,
it's going to be awful.
Which you have respected it.
If he said,
oh,
you know,
I want to box a few matches first and
then get to roy.
I think he's just talking shit.
He was just having a good time.
Probably didn't expect anybody to run
with it.
He didn't expect people to analyze it.
That's the guy who you know.
And that video.
This guy,
he's an real boxer,
huh?
Oh yeah.
You're knocked out.
David haye before.
His name is tony bellew.
Oh dude,
that,
that's,
that guy is a legit boxer.
he just got stopped by that bad ass
russian motherfucker on a well look what
he's doing.
Tv really recently,
lIke his guy.
that's it.
These are top flight boxer.
So for him to knock him out,
of course it was just.
He's so good man.
So for him to do it accidentally makes
complete total sense.
Well look at the.
Yeah,
that guy is a beast man.
That's like a legit top flight boxer.
so he's in there even just accidentally
getting punched in the face by to see
the movie.
I'll tell you tHat Michael Jordan
talking shit to recover and get back to
training and,
and,
and
filming after that.
In the heavyweight class,
you never saw abs until the movies.
You never.
It was always like,
I know,
right.
You know,
they were like,
they were like basically punching bags
now.
Now it's like they have to be.
So
tyson.
You saw abs when he came out of prison.
Remember that?
I guess when you fought peter mcneely,
dude,
he was prison jacked.
That was like maybe the scariest tyson
ever.
Like they finally
released him and all he'd been doing in
jail.
I don't think he could box in jail,
so I think he was just lifting weights.
You remember he was super,
super jacked when he got out of jail.
He was.
Yeah.
See,
go to tyson.
Pei.
That's tyson versus peter mcneely.
That was in 1995.
It looks good.
They're terrifying.
That was the most terrifying movie tyson
ever.
He just looked like he was made out of
steel.
Just a tank of a man,
and I'll never forget the fucking way in
or the stare down rather because during
the steer down,
peter mcneely signed up for that fight
knowing that he's a tough guy who's
going to take a fucking vicious beating.
That's what he signed up for.
He knew what he was doing.
He knew he going to give it his all,
but he knew if you had to bet,
most people were not betting on Peter
Mcdonald.
Yeah,
but you could see it in tyson's face
when he's staring them down.
There's this crazy.
He's following him everywhere.
He goes like a predator dude.
It's like a predator who can't wait to
get the green light to let the genie out
of the bottle.
Watch this.
This is tysons first fight like peter is
kind of looking down and you look over
time.
So we'll get his eyes.
Dad is fucking terrifying
if you're looking at that and you know,
smiling and trying to like,
he's trying to like make light of it.
Oh my god.
He looks just like a prison guard dude.
He.
Oh yeah,
he does.
That's really guard here.
After the green mile hair,
I sat next.
I sat next to tyson at after the,
at the charlie sheen roast and made a
lot of jokes about him and uh,
afterwards dice call me.
I didn't really know.
Dice at the time,
called me like a couple of weeks later,
he's like,
jeff dice.
He's like,
he's like,
he's like basically said that he
couldn't believe I said those things to
Mike Tyson.
Like he was offended and I go,
what do you mean?
He's like,
do you have any idea what that animal
could have done
two feet away.
We've been friends ever since,
but I didn't,
I didn't think about tyson.
He seemed like a pussy cat at the time,
at the time.
But if that was tyson from like 1986,
I think if I watched an old fight.
Yeah,
by the end of the night.
I'm literally like laughing and it was a
lap.
Well once loved it.
Yeah.
He loves jokes.
He could take jokes.
Oh yeah,
but you wouldn't want to be
that.
Imagine if I said I don't want to piss
you off mike,
if you would do that to your face,
imagine what you would do to
basically the only celebrity to ever
pull off a face mask.
Face tats.
I thought.
No.
Who else has done it?
What?
Celebrity feud.
Charles manson.
Well,
those,
those mumble rapper dudes.
Yeah.
Like postman
alone loan type characters to kashi.
Sixty nine.
But he was the first by a long stretch
and you're being pulled off as if he
pulled that off.
Still.
Mike tyson not good.
You know what I mean?
Hope gucci mane.
Oh,
that's right.
He had the ice cream cone.
Was that first though?
I feel like wow,
close.
Probably same time.
Wow.
That's a commitment that got.
Has that on his face anymore.
This new pictures.
It looks like.
Get that off.
That'll get you removed.
Yeah,
they live.
They can lead you that shit off,
but I haven't,
but it looks like somebody carved into
his face.
It doesn't even look like a tat.
well that's because it's fresh because
that's like right after it got made.
It's still.
They're not as a bright.
Let me see.
That man's got an ice cream cone on his
face,
but now it's yogurt.
It's just different time.
Is that today though?
He's got more tests to.
Oh,
so they're all over the place.
That dude's always smiling.
Ever since you got out of jail.
He seems like the happiest guy in the
world for real.
He's got a beautiful good on him.
They looked.
The tattoos look good.
I said,
but why is there ice cream like right
there?
Like does he have a tongue where he's
like,
hey look,
I can look ice cream.
No,
because then we don't want to be able to
lick the bottom part.
He Wouldn't even get the real ice cream
cone somewhere else and he's got a lot
of tattoos.
Yeah.
It looks good though.
But the pearls takes him the mean out of
the highest tattoo you have to your
face.
Oh,
it goes up to my shoulder.
Both arms.
Basically the same.
So you can see all your tattoos.
Yeah.
Don't have any other ones.
Just these.
No tattoos.
Jeff.
I'm thinking of getting a tramp stamp.
Dave and I are going to get them to say.
Come on.
Mine says free wifi.
Mine's going to say too legit to shit.
I'm going.
I'm going with watch out.
Terrible ahead.
Fear has keep on trucking.
Tattoo side.
In hebrew it's the only tattoo.
It's preposterous.
Keep on trucking.
Yeah.
Jamie?
Yeah,
he's gotta.
Keep on trucking.
Tattoo.
I'm right about this.
Right.
I was looking for,
it says keep on trucking.
Who used to have it was tony danza you
said of like keep on trucking.
I was like a thing that people used to
say.
I'm sure I had to keep on trucking patch
or tee shirt and a hat.
Like what was that?
What was going on to keep on trucking?
Hang in there,
baby.
That was one.
Keep on trucking.
Nobody had hanging.
Blah.
I'm sure people got hang in there.
Baby tattoos,
right?
What am I saying?
Nobody should have done it when he got.
This is a bumping my cat.
Shut the fuck up.
Is that mine?
Yeah.
You can put it near your dave's whole
porn hat that I don't even have one of
these.
Yeah,
you do.
I've given you two of them.
That show was fun.
That was a good one.
Joe.
You really rocked that show.
It was fun.
That was a great show.
That should never take that off.
The air bumping mix.
Yeah,
but I hope it's not a.
I hope it's not a bad light.
I give him always a hat from every show.
He always helps me out and they go
nowhere.
The shows.
That's not true.
Now this one's a hit.
I'm hoping this is our moment in that
kind of jinxes.
This is our moment.
This is the talking flip phone.
If you're worried about gypsy curse,
don't give up.
You talk about your last special.
Took a long time to get together.
This tickled took us a couple years ago.
Not even.
It came together pretty quick from
montreal to a year later we shot it,
but like I feel like it's also like
about our friendship or whatever you
wanna call it for 25 years,
so it kind of puts,
uh,
puts a nice button on it.
Oh,
it's the first button maybe.
What are you doing over there?
You're mixing up.
Do I just don't want to leave my asHes
here?
Dave has a lot of weird cigarette coffee
kind of straw so you're letting me smoke
in here.
was like,
thank you.
I'm glad it worked.
It works great.
If tHere's any like low spectrum people
watching our show,
you can wish.
Watch dave and just cigarettes.
You'll learn a lot.
In my weird phobias.
Dice was the reason why I put it in my
dyson.
How much is he smoking now?
He doesn't smoke as I haven't.
I haven't seen him in quite a while.
But last time you did the podcast,
was he.
Did he smoke the last time or a time
before that?
He takes time off.
I think for awhile he would just bring
them on the smoking.
He's smoking smoking a lot.
I saw him.
I came on his new podcast recently and
um,
it's uh,
I'm,
I'm over here.
He made me,
he made me pretend he was half an hour
late even though I was 10 minutes.
He had a whole bit work that where I had
to go in the studio and just wait and
talk to myself basically that he has to
come in pretending he's late.
that was the only direction for an hour
and a half.
It's so funny,
man.
That's,
he cracks me up so much my first time.
So my second time headlining was opening
for ray romano in poughkeepsie and dice
is at the height of his fame.
I've dressed like I'm like,
you had to be to even get work.
And it's like I'm a jersey comic,
1990,
91 and dices at the,
at the,
uh,
poughkeepsie civic center right next
door to the comedy club.
And uh,
and our hotel,
we heard dice was staying there.
People were pulling the fire alarm.
It's like it was like the biggest base
of rockstar.
Yeah.
Pulling fire alarms.
Try to get everybody evacuated so dice
would come out.
Right.
Fine.
Finally our show on his shows on
saturday,
friday night.
Now ray romano was headlining at
poughkeepsie whenever closed the
bananas.
Oh yeah.
I remember that place.
And just,
I'm up there.
I'm doing my 10 slash 12 minute opening
and through the darkness,
this guy I kind of recognized from like
news articles was a club soda.
Kenny comes through the darkness with a
note friday night and uh,
the note just says please welcome the
king of comedy day.
So as I read it and the place was fine,
right?
Like so nice.
WAlks on stage,
he does whatever,
like a 15 minute guests at the crowd
goes crazy.
They loved it.
And then I learned a lot.
Actually.
Ray romano came up as the headliner who
was not known at all.
He wasn't on tv yet and killed raising
crops,
but I Really learned like,
oh,
you know what the audience will follow.
We'll watch a great comic.
No matter what.
Just happened.
Ray was in his prime back then too
for read jimmy's comedy,
allie queens and ray was.
That was when ray was just.
He had done,
hbo had done something on hbo,
but he was just a machine man.
People like people didn't realize how
mean he is a great time.
Those guys that people don't talk about
when they talk about great standup
comics because he hasn't put a lot of
stuff out there in a long time ever
since.
Everybody loves raymond.
A lot of stuff.
As far as the standup,
he just shot a netflix special at the
seller so that should be coming out
soon.
But you're right,
he hasn't put out anything until.
I think this is like his first real our.
So he.
I know he was working with Kevin James.
He did a bunch of gigs together.
Some I'm friends with kevin.
He goes on the road but he still murders
was my point.
That's right.
He's still merge
comic.
He was always so funny and you could
always.
Someone wants to describe it like you
could airdrop him anywhere and his go
kill.
Yeah,
like anywhere in America before people
relatable.
We're all kinda the same,
like we all kind of lift into the same
stuff now,
but he's another guy like,
couldn't be a nicer guy.
One of the best.
He's always been really cool to me and
you know,
like do the height of his fame never
changed for a second.
[inaudible] never kind of weird how the
asshole sort of disappear eventually.
You don't even know where they evaporate
too when I'm still here.
You know,
you're talking to,
you're talking about you're a comedIan.
You almost before you were an american.
That's when.
And that doesn't mean I don't love my
car.
I'm not trying to act like I'm very
aware.
Of course.
You're so attached to being a comedian
that's in my blood in a way that,
well,
do you feel more comfortable
comics and how devastating would it be
if the other comics didn't want you
around that man without a country
that's,
that's where it gets fucking dark man,
right?
Yeah.
That's where it.
So anybody who falls into that group,
like if you fucked up,
like the whole thing is to be friends
with the comedian.
Hang is what it's about,
you know,
the hang.
So how did you feel?
Let me ask you,
how did you feel when you were in self,
um,
you know,
you,
you pulled yourself out of the world at
a comedy store where you started,
did you feel like on a desert island by
yourself or did you find community at
the other clubs or.
I never found the same thing,
uh,
but I just kept working and I always was
working with ari and joey and dunkin.
I still kept working with those guys.
So I was like,
I was working with most of the same
comics and I was just doing practice
sets at the ice house and at the improv
I remember all that.
It's just,
to me it was more,
it was,
you know,
the hang was on the same.
I would do my psets the improv and just
get the fuck out of there.
There's no place to hang out.
It's not like the same how you get to do
fun for sure.
You got to do stand up on the spot,
roast battle,
made room a oh are and whatever.
You'd figured out in the parking lot
without him and then a podcast in the
basement.
You could literally,
you can put a gym in there.
You'd probably never leave everything in
that place.
You could do three.
I've done three shows.
No,
I've done four shows in a night because
one night I did two sets in the main
room,
one set and the belly room and one set
in the or because it was to show.
That's crazy to follow this
motherfucker.
So many times everything I ever taped
with you on the show,
I developed funnel having to try to
follow him.
Wow.
Like steam rolling like civilization.
Everything from harvey weinstein to like
his own inner fucking craziness.
That's,
that's all in 20 minutes.
So it's like the,
the crowds,
you know,
like uh,
like a get spoiled when they see so many
great acts like just come by and just
for like 10 bucks,
20 bucks,
whatever.
They get to see chris rock,
you,
joe.
and like,
just like people dropping by and working
on stuff they like.
Is it like this all the time?
Like you don't even get it.
You just saw a $500 show for like two
drinks.
You know what?
I always say that to the people at the
cellar to if you're a fan of comedy,
it's time.
That's what missing new year's right
together.
And I attribute all this to the thing
that you hate the web.
The internet did all this.
That's the reason why everybody's aware
of how fun it is to go to a live comedy
show.
How fun it is to watch guys.
Like they'll go to see you at the store
and then they go to see you again six
months later and go,
oh,
that fucking comedy central and hbo and
showtime and netflix and all the ones
that comedy central definitely made it
for sure.
Comedy central for sure.
All those things definitely attribute to
it.
But what about evening at the improv
tube is one of the biggest factors.
The fact that people can watch,
stand up on youtube,
that's a giant factor.
The amount of people that are watching
youtube is off the charts and the fact
that they can Just type in right now,
Jeff Ross,
standup comedy poom and instantaneously
get it and a lot of those clips come
from comedy central,
hbo and all those other places,
which is great.
It's like it's all.
It all contributes.
Not one thing that did it,
but I think the one big important factor
was this new channel of distribution and
that's the internet,
whether it's netflix,
which is probably one of the biggest
thing right now for stand up comedy
specials ever.
RiGht.
And there's never been a thing like
netflix,
well look what we're doing three
episodes.
It's like,
exactly.
Who else would let you do that?
Well will take the pressure oFf like one
shiny special,
you know,
like you can do,
be more creative with how you present
your art.
Oh yeah.
Well if you wanted to do a two parter
next time,
you could narrow it right already did
with.
That was not the one that he's working
on right now,
but the last one that's right in the
same place.
Yeah.
That red,
so good man,
he's out there.
Our review was harping on was Like the
comedy is
completely reinvented lately,
but do it as a series.
You could do whatever you want that as a
comedy fan,
netflix is perfect because you know you
don't have to.
You get to control what you see,
you know,
and you can watch it and stop it and
watch it more and even stop it.
I was watching her show when it came out
last night.
I was just laying in bed watching our
new show because I was by my sister and
like when it gets to the end of the
episodes,
you've got nowhere.
That remote is try to get you to binge.
Come on,
you don't understand.
It's like,
oh man.
Another episode for this episode ends
with dave just looking in the camera and
being like,
our next episode starts at five,
four,
three.
I heard that you
god.
See the new mike judge,
an animated show about country music
called the band.
What is it called?
Road stories from something that sounds
great.
yeah,
he is another guy,
man.
That guy posted down the nominal.
My love,
ella was just talking about it on this
podcast.
What is it called?
Tales from the tour bus from the tour
buses supposed to be insanely funny.
It's about George Jones and all those
guys,
but it's all like gunplay and drugs and
chaos,
country music stuff,
and then they animate like the story.
It's really cool.
He really is a talented guy.
Man.
Funk music creates this one.
Uh,
yes,
that's it.
Here's one of the ways I thought it was
all country guys.
Yeah,
I thought so too.
But there's a different maybe separate
seasons or something that the highway
man click on highway man.
So that's with Willie Willie Nelson.
Willie nelson.
Oh,
spotify,
waylon jennings,
kris kristofferson and Johnny Cash.
That's an episode.
That's just a song.
highway been.
So that's the song.
The highwaymen when they all got song,
that mega group.
Yeah,
but that's not an episode of the show
is.
This is a playlist of songs.
Oh.
Oh,
confusion.
So I went to their webpage here and.
Oh,
I get it.
This must be a new season whether they
use in the seventies,
people.
Do you know that song highwayman?
Yeah,
that's star stars across the universe to
vive and when I reached the other side,
that's a creepy song,
right?
It's about reincarnation and you never
fade away.
Yeah.
People built this country.
Yeah,
blood,
sweat and.
But getting them all together.
I wonder what that was like.
I know,
right?
Those,
those guys.
How's it going?
That was young gun or doing,
you know boys.
It's already 3:30.
Oh wow.
Time flies.
Rogan.
When you're fucking amazing man.
When everything we do is like,
you get two minutes or.
Yeah.
What a great hang man.
It's so fun to be able to express
yourself and
thank you.
What's so fun to have you guys on?
I fucking loved it.
I wish you were here more often.
We can do this anytime you want to do
it.
Dude,
you're good to us,
but you're great.
Tick comedy and honestly I have to tell
ya,
you know,
you've for the young guys,
when they heard that I was going to be
on here,
they were like basically creaming
because you're,
you're,
you are the shit and you really are
mentally
shit.
Fuck.
Stop making me feel bad.
Dude.
You're the shit.
You're going to come on stage with us
some to do it.
I'll bump mike's.
Bring your hat.
I'll do it.
I'll have a bump in my fucking hell of
him or somebody like that.
Netflix.
We'll hook you up.
Give you one with velcro.
It's even better.
I like velcro.
Nice exact right amount of distance.
You know,
you don't have to rely on those buttons.
Rogan's got to pick up his kids and take
them out for elk talk.
I can only imagine the amount of merge.
Your kids have to come up.
Put on this shirt.
All the birch that people bring in kids.
Grab your bow and arrow.
We're going out for dinner.
They have a warehouse full of it.
All right,
ladies and gentlemen,
david tell you can find me on twitter,
but he doesn't use the internet.
A real Jeff Ross as you on instagram,
right?
Yes.
It is your david.
Tell on instagram.
Do you ever post that iphone two and a
shout out
to all the uh,
uh,
which macola I did a food drive in
philly the other day,
a preston and steve.
It was awesome.
I love those guys.
Yeah,
they really are cool and this is one of
the biggest one in the country.
It was great to be part of it.
Somebody cool comics there,
so I would just say thank you again for
avenue,
for a beautiful human being,
Jeffrey Ross,
beautiful person.
Love you.
Love you guys.
Bye.